RETIREMENT COMMITTEE HEARING.
FOR WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIXTH --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEM TWENTY
ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY. ONE
ITEM HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
AGENDA AND THAT IS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SIX SIXTY
FOUR HAS BEEN PULLED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
AND THERE ARE FIVE BILLS ON
CONSENT TODAY ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
THREE THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB.
THREE SIX FIVE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B..
TEN THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A.
B..
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX A SINCE WE DO
NOT HAVE -- ENOUGH OF MEMBERS
HERE FOR A QUORUM WE WILL.
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
START WITH OUR FIRST BILL ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB THREE FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU.
FOR BEING HERE SO PROMPTLY
MORNING AFTER MORNING PLEASE FOR
HOLLY AND STAFF THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB THREE
ONE FOUR AND THANKS FOR THE WORK
AB THREE ONE FOUR WOULD
UNIFORMLY APPLY A FLOOR. FOR
REASONABLE RELEASE TIME OFF
WITHOUT LOSS OF COMPENSATION TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
AND PROVIDE CLARITY ON SPECIFIC
DUTIES ALLOWED DURING.
RELEASE TIME UNDER EXISTING LAW
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
ALLOW EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES.
QUOTE UNQUOTE REASONABLE TIME
OFF WITHOUT LOSS OF COMPENSATION
TO PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS SUCH AS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
AND MATTERS BEFORE PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONS THIS IS REFERRED TO
AS RELEASE TIME.
IN PREVIOUS YEARS TO HAVE BEEN A
GROWING NUMBER OF ATTACKS ON
WORKERS RIGHTS TO THWART THEIR
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
COLLECTIVE POWER.
OTHER CALIFORNIA HAS A POLICY OF
PROVIDING REASONABLE TIME OFF
WITHOUT LOSS OF PAY TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES.
THE LAW IS INEFFECTIVE IN
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES TO
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BECAUSE CURRENT LAW IS
INCONSISTENT.
ACROSS DIFFERENT SECTORS OF
EMPLOYMENT AND THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THAT CONSISTENCY THAT
CERTAINTY THAT UNIFORMITY.
IN ORDER FOR PUBLIC INPUT TO
BENEFIT FROM THE RIGHTS TO
REPRESENTATION THEY NEED TO BE
CERTAIN OF THEIR PAID TIME OFF
ALLOWANCES AB THREE ONE FOUR
WITH LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
BY CREATING THAT UNIFORMITY
ACROSS ALL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SECTOR LABOR RELATION LAWS I
RECKON ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
EQUAL RIGHTS TO REASONABLE.
PAID TIME OFF TO ENGAGE IN
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MICHELLE
CASTRO.
SEIU SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK
YOU SHOULD REMEMBER BONTA AND WE
ARE GOING TO LIMIT ADDITIONALLY
TO FIVE MINUTES FOR OF SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE SHOT HOUSE OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION.
I MUST MISTER BONTA SAID THIS IS
A MEASURE OF BUILDING OFF OF
EXISTING LAW IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT -- RIGHT TO RELEASE
TIME.
AND NOT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
HOWEVER SOME EMPLOYERS.
HAVE AGREED TO MORE RELEASE TIME
IN THE STATUE ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IN THE STATUTE.
BUT THIS BILL REALLY DOES IS
ATTEMPT TO LEVEL PLAYING GROUND
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
CURRENT LAW LIMITS A
SUBSTANTIALLY TO THE AMOUNT OF
RELEASE TIME HOWEVER EMPLOYERS.
CAN ASSIGN AS MANY STAFF AS THEY
LIKE -- TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
INTERESTS ARE RICH -- REPRESENT
AN EMPLOYER RELATIONS THEY CAN
HIRE OUTSIDE ATTORNEYS THEY CAN
ASSIGN THEIR STAFF FULL TIME SO
THEY ARE AT A SIGNIFICANT
ADVANTAGE OVER EMPLOYEES THIS
BILL JUST ATTEMPTS TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO EVEN THINGS OUT A
LITTLE BIT.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T GIVE
EMPLOYEES UNLIMITED MA'AM TIMES
SAYS.
A REASONABLE PLEASE MAY BE
GRANTED A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND THEN THE EMPLOYER AND
THE UNION NEGOTIATE FOR WHAT IS
REASONABLE BECAUSE WHAT IS
REASONABLE MENDOCINO.
MAY NOT BE REASONABLE LOS
ANGELES SO IT'S KIND OF A
CAREFUL BALANCE BETWEEN
BARGAINING AND THE STATUTE WHICH
WHAT.
WE ASK.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JOSH THE PROCESS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION FOR A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND I SAID BEEN STATED THIS
PROVIDES UNIFORMITY AND PROVIDE
THE CLARITY DEBT OF THINGS THAT
WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD IN TERMS OF
RELEASE TIME.
AND THIS PER ENSURES THAT THAT
DEPLOYS NOW HAVE IT SPELLED OUT
AND IN A UNIFORM PROCESS WITHIN
A SINGLE STATUTE.
AS OPPOSED TO BEING SPREAD OUT.
VARIOUS THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS PAT MARATHON
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SITE IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE BILL FOR REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER AND CREATE OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
MORNING.
HERE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DEALING GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND SEE SACK
WHICH ARE IN THE ASSEMBLY PURRS
COMMITTEE -- RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO
THIS LEGISLATION WHAT WE FOUND.
MOST OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL TO BE REASONABLE AND COMMON
PRACTICE.
AMONGST OUR ORGANIZATIONS.
THE SPECIFIC PROVISION AS IT
RELATES TO EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION
IS WHERE WE HAVE CONCERNS.
THAT PROVISION WAS NEGOTIATED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WAS.
PASSED AS PART OF A TRAILER BILL
THAT THOSE NEGATION NEGOTIATIONS
TOOK PLACE BETWEEN.
THE ADMINISTRATION THE PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
N. LABOR.
AND ONCE THAT WAS.
ONCE AGREEMENT WAS COMPLETED WAS
PUT IN AB.
ONE NINETEEN AND THAT BILL WAS
SUPPORTED BY LABOR -- THE
PROVISION AS FAR AS RELEASE TIME
WAS A VERY SPECIFIC PROVISION
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED.
THE E. EMPLOYERS -- THE THE THE
PURPOSE OF INSURING THAT WOULD
STATE IN THE M. O. U..
WAS RECOGNITION THAT EMPLOYERS
FAIRY AND SIZE AND SCOPE.
SO WITH SOME OF OUR PUBLIC
AGENCIES SOME OF OUR SPECIAL
DISTRICT WE MIGHT HAVE NINE
UNION EMPLOYEES TOTAL.
OTHERS HAVE THOUSANDS -- THE THE
AGENCY WITH NINE EMPLOYEES MIGHT
DO ONE ORIENTATION. FOR THE ONE
NEW EMPLOYEE THEY GET EVERY
COUPLE OF YEARS.
WHERE AS SOME OF OUR LARGER
EMPLOYERS MAYBE YOU'VE GOT
TWELVE DIFFERENT BARGAINING
UNITS?
THEY'RE HAVING ORIENTATIONS
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
AND SO THE THE REASON THAT THAT
THAT PROVISION DIDN'T INCLUDE --
RELEASE TIME AN AUTOMATIC PAY
FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES.
WHAT'S THE THEY CAN NEGOTIATE
AND WORK OUT AN AGREEMENT
AMONGST THE PUBLIC AGENCIES.
DEPENDING ON THE NEEDS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN WORKING --
WE'VE BEEN HAD WE'VE HAD THE
ORIENTATIONS IN FOR TWO YEARS --
NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
ORIENTATIONS HAVE GONE TO
BINDING ARBITRATION TO RESOLVE.
DIFFERENCES AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CAN REACH AN AGREEMENT ON
HOW THIS ORIENTATIONS WOULD TAKE
PLACE WERE WHO WOULD PARTICIPATE
OR HOW IT HAPPENED.
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST THAT
WE DO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH AND
GOES BACK ON AN AGREEMENT THAT
WAS MADE.
JUST TWO YEARS AGO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE'RE OPPOSE LESS MET
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NO -- ONE FEEDBACK THE
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY ELIZABETH
THAT'S ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
WE'RE STUCK OUTSIDE RUNNING
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU -- DOES
RING OUT OF ORDER SEPTEMBER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL PIMENTEL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THE STUCK OUTSIDE MAY CONSUMERS
OF AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT IS WELL JAKE OF RECORD FOR
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS FROM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I'M
SURE BUT THE OTHER THE OTHER
OPPOSITE ENDS OUTSIDE.
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE.
THE DOOR DOWN.
BANGING ON THE DOOR -- ARE WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MISSED BUT IF YOU
MAYBE WOULDN'T RESPOND.
TO THE TWO I REMEMBER THE
LEGISLATION TWO YEARS AGO AND
THE AGREEMENT THAT.
AND OF SIGNED ON TO AND WHAT HAS
CHANGED SINCE THEN.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO RESPOND
ACTUALLY THE AGREEMENT REGARDING
RELEASE TIME WITH NOT IN AB.
ONE NINETEEN THE THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION THE YEAR PRIOR OVER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WAS
NOT SIGNED IN ENACTED.
AB ONE NINETEEN WAS ACTUALLY A
PROPOSAL BY.
GOVERNOR BROWN WHICH WE ALL THAT
AGREED TO WAS NOT A NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENT THE YEAR PRIOR WAS A
DIFFERENT BILL AND THAT WAS
NEGOTIATED -- SINCE THAT TIME.
EVERY PUBLIC EMPLOYER HAS AGREED
TO RELEASE TIME. FOR NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION SO ALLOW
PLACE -- WANNA CORRECT THERE HAS
BEEN ARBITRATIONS OVER EMPLOYERS
REFUSING TO GRANT -- EMPLOYEES
RELEASE TIME.
AND ALL THOSE ARBITRATIONS
OVERWHELMINGLY SAID YOU MUST
GRANT EMPLOYEES TIME TO
PARTICIPATE RELEASE TIME AND YOU
MUST PAY THAT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS CODIFYING
[inaudible]
ALREADY WET.
ARBITRATORS HAVE BROUGHT.
D. V. D. ARBITRATION WAS. TO THE
ORIENTATION IS THE WORK. TO THE
YOUR YES THEY WERE.
IF THAT'S THE CASE I STAND
CORRECTED. FOR YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OF QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN.
NINE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION OFFLINE --
OUTSIDE OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
CLARIFY YOU KNOW WHAT WAS TO GO
SHE TO WHAT WAS DISCUSSED WHAT
WAS NOT BUT I I THINK WHAT WE
WILL.
END UP SEEING IS THAT FOR A NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION THAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE -- PLACE WHERE
RELEASE TIME SHOULD BE GIVEN AN
AND IT'S GIVEN.
MOST EVERYWHERE TODAY BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT CONSISTENCY
THAT UNIFORMITY THAT -- THAT
CERTAINTY THAT CLARITY AND THAT
BUILT THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T --
PROVIDE A ANY MASSIVE CHANGES IN
SUCH SUBSTANTIVE.
LAW BUT IT DOES CLARIFY GREAT
CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES I
SO IT'S NEEDED AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA APPRECIATE
THAT AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND
TAKE THE BILL.
UP THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
TEST THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU STOP THANK YOU -- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVEL.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
ALL THESE PEOPLE HERE TO SEE YOU.
THE YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE YOU.
IT IN EVERY JUST A CAR WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER FOR A BE A THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT RECEIVED WHEN YOU
CHAIR AND WILL COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I FIRST WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT SIX SIX TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE CAREER
PATHWAY AND SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WHO EDUCATE AND CARE FOR OUR
EARLIEST LEARNERS CALIFORNIA'S
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION WORK
FIRST IS COMPRISED PRIMARILY OF
WOMEN AND PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF
COLOR.
THIS IS A WORKFORCE THAT OFTEN
DOES NOT EARN A LIVABLE WAGE AND
QUALIFIES FOR THE SAME SUBSIDIES
THAT THE FAMILIES THEY SERVE USE.
STABILITY IS BROUGHT TO THE EASY
WORK FORCE WHEN A SOLID
FOUNDATION IN QUALITY AND
REIMBURSEMENT IS IN PLACE AND WE
KNOW WHEN FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CARE.
PARENTS ARE MORE PRODUCTIVE IN
THE WORKFORCE AND CHILDREN ARE
SET UP TO SIXTY LEADER IN
EDUCATION AND IN LIFE.
THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON CHILD CARE WORKED
TIRELESSLY OVER TWO YEARS TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IN ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES WITH THE CURRENT EASY
WORK FIRST ONE OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO SUPPORT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE.
HOME PROVIDERS WAS LICENSE AND
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR.
CALIFORNIA RUNS A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR A DAY WORKFORCE BUT OUR
CHILD CARE OPTIONS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES DO NOT MEET THAT NEED
NOR SUPPORT THOSE WHO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE.
THIS BILL PROFESSIONAL EYES IS
AND CREATE STABILITY FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY MAKING
QUALITY TRAINING AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDERS THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PROVIDES
A HOLISTIC FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS
BOTH PROVIDER PAY INEQUITY AND
THE LACK OF ACCESSIBLE CHILDCARE.
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS BEFORE YOU
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY AT A CO
AUTHORS AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT A LINE THE BILL WITH THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
ALSO IT'S REFLECTS STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNS ABOUT INCLUSION JOINING
ME TODAY IS HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
AMMASH A GRIFFIN A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER FROM APPLE VALLEY AND
THE ON AIR INNER WHO.
IS REPRESENTING SCA EVEN ASKED
ME AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MANY MAY
HAVE VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
WELCOME.
MORNING MY NAME IS THE MEASURE
GRIFFIN AND FOR THE PAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS I HAVE BEEN A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE
APPLE VALLEY VICTORVILLE AREA.
I AM ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
VICTOR VALLEY CHILD CARE
ASSOCIATION AND HOLD A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I
CURRENTLY CARE FOR FOR TEN
CHILDREN EIGHT OF WHICH ARE ON
STATE SUBSIDY I ALSO HAVE THREE
CHILDREN OF MY OWN.
FIFTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
SEVEN I AM ALSO A PROUD MEMBER
OF AT THE AYE YOU LOCAL NINETY
NINE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN.
NINE I LIKE FORTY THOUSAND
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PORK
COUNTLESS HOURS NURTURING AND
EDUCATING INFANTS.
TODDLERS AND SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
I AM PASSIONATE ABOUT MY WORK
BECAUSE EVERY DAY I GET TO HELP
OUR YOUNGEST MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN THE FILL THEIR
POTENTIAL.
BUT THERE IS A TROUBLE INSIDE TO
CHILD CARE BEYOND DIRTY DIAPERS
AND TEMPER TANTRUMS MANY DON'T
SEE.
WHILE I SUPPORT WORKING PARENTS
VERY STRONGLY SO THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES CAN
FOR THEIR MOST VALUABLE
TREASURES.
THEIR CHILDREN I ALSO STRUGGLE
WITH POVERTY WAGES.
THIS DECISION MAKERS SAY I DO
VALUABLE WORK BUT THE LAW AND MY
REALITY SAY OTHERWISE.
THE LAW MAKES PROVIDERS BILL
DISPOSABLE.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT WORTHY OF
BASIC PROTECTIONS LIKE THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION I AM AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR AND THE STATE
WITH THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
IN THE WORLD YES I DO NOT EARN A
LIVING WAGE INSTEAD AT SOME
POINTS PROVIDERS CAN QUALIFY FOR
THE SAME CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES
THAT I PROVIDE.
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE THESE HAVE
DIRE CONSEQUENCES AND THEY DID
FOR ME AND TWO THOUSAND NINE I
WAS CLOSE TO LOSING MY HOME.
BECAUSE I WAS NOT BEING PAID ON
TIME AND SUFFER FROM LOW
ENROLLMENT WHILE LOSE SOMEONE'S
HOME IS HARD ENOUGH FOR A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IT IS
COMPLETELY TRAUMATIC.
IF WE LOSE OUR HOMES WE LOSE OUR
LIVELIHOOD AND DEPRIVE OUR EARLY
CHILD CARE EDUCATION.
MY STORY IS ONE OF MANY AND A
GLARING EXAMPLE OF THE DEEP
CRACKS IN CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
CARE SYSTEM THAT NOT ONLY IMPACT
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
BUT OUR CHILDREN AND PARENTS.
WHO RELY ON US?
THAT'S WHY I LIKE CHILDCARE
PROVIDER.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE MY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER SISTER SITTING BEHIND
ME FROM AS SEE I YOU LOCAL FIVE
TWENTY ONE AND YOU D. W. ASKED
ME HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS. TO FORMER UNION A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WITH THE
STATE WE WANT TO JOIN PROVIDERS
AND ELEVEN OTHER STATES WHO HAVE
SEEN IMPROVEMENTS TO THEIR LIVES.
WE WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
CHILDREN AND PARENTS WE SERVE
FOR OUR PROFESSION AS A REAL
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WE LOVE KAREN FOR IT
EVERY DAY AND PUTTING FOOD ON
THEIR TABLE FOR OUR OWN CHILDREN.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE FOR A. B..
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO FORWARD
WITH WITH THE NEXT WITNESS WOULD
LIKE TO THAT WHICH FORMED COULD.
PLEASE A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SENATOR HILL [inaudible]
NO HERO.
MORRELL HERE JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE MITCHELL PAN.
VERY GOOD WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM IN THAT WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT.
TO SENATOR I'M DIONNE AREA AND
I'M HERE JUST FOR PROVIDERS
TECHNICAL SAYS ANYTHING VERY
LONG QUESTIONS HAVE YOU --
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
AND WHAT WE'D LIKE YOU TO DO IS
JUST TELL US WHO YOU ARE AND WHO
YOU REPRESENTING AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL WOULD BE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NANCY
HARVEY AND I'VE BEEN A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE CITY
OF OAKLAND FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF SEIU
LOCAL FIVE TWO ONE AND I
STRONGLY STAND HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BROWN BEAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US MY NAME
IS HOLLY MY HEART AND I HAVE
BEEN A PRESCHOOL.
DIRECTOR AND EDUCATOR FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AND EIGHTY THREE
SEVEN EIGHT IS.
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SUPPORTS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS WHICH ARE IN ESSENCE
THE APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
HI I'M TIM ALDERMAN I'VE BEEN A
MEMBER OF THE S. HE ARE YOU AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN A DAYCARE
PROVIDER. FOR FOUR YEARS I BILL
DAYCARE AND I CHANGE DIAPERS
THANK YOU.
MINE MY NAME IS.
LAURA AND I HAVE BEEN A
FORESHOCK WRITER FOR IN THE CITY
OF PARTY HERE FOR ONE YEAR I
JUST STARTED BUT I'M LOVING IT.
AND I AM A MEMBER OF A CA YOU --
FOR LOOKING FIVE TWENTY ONE AND
I'M HERE -- FOR THE SUPPORT OF
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THANK YOU. ONE OF THE
AS WE NOTICE A MAN AB SPANGLE
THERE THE FRESNO BEE.
A SINGLE SAFE MESSES UP ANOTHER
PROFESORA DE THANK YOU FOR THE
EMPLOYEE BARBARELLA VISIT THEY
SAID THAT THEY THANK YOU JAZZ
YOU GROW WITH YOUR C. W. S. AND
STATES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING MR MEMBERS OF REALLY YOU
WANT TO HAVE YOU W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY AS A CO
SPONSOR AND ON BEHALF HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOME CARE PROVIDERS.
OF WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORT
ECCENTRIC BUT THE BURNING RIGHT
ONLY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CELESTE
GLENDALE AND I'VE BEEN A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE CITY
OF TILLERY FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF SCA YOU
FIVE TO ONE AND I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU.
FOR COMING FROM TO LARA TO
DELIVER IT TODAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE GONNA BE
THIS I HAVE BEEN A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE CITY
OF AYE SO YEAH. FOR ELEVEN YEARS
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL.
FIVE TWO I STAND HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN SMITH I HAVE
BEEN A DAY CARE PROVIDER IN THE
CITY OF TULARE FOR TWO YEARS.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SEIU
LOCAL.
FIVE TWO ONE AND I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE DIVISION CARPOOLING
GOING ON THIS.
I THINK IT'S HOPE IS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'VE BEEN UP
PROVIDER HOME PROVIDER SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND I'M ALWAYS
HERE TO SUPPORT AB. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU.
THE MORNING I'M SUZANNE ALVARADO
AND I'VE BEEN A PROVIDER FOR THE
PAST FOURTEEN YEARS AND I'M HERE
FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI.
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MORNING EVERYONE RUNNING I AM
GENERAL BLISS I AM A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
CITY OF BALLPARK.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER AND
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF LOCAL NINETY
NINE AND THAT'S FORT OF A. B.
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALSO A REGULAR
MEDICARE PROVIDER FROM SAN JOSE.
AND I'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT AB THREE SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH GARCIA AND
I'M FROM SUMMER TO DO.
HI I AM FROM LOCAL. NINETY NINE
AND I'VE BEEN IN DAYCARE FOR
NINE YEARS AND I'M HERE TO OR AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS SABINA CREWS I
AM OF A LIVING IN A WHERE I HAVE
MY OWN DEVOID OF THE YEAR.
I'M SUPPOSED TO A. B.
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PATRICIA
MORAN AND I'M.
I HAVE I WOULD HAVE ON THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDER FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND THE CITY OF SAN JOSE.
I'M WILL ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
ACLU I TWO ONE AND I IS I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT AB PRESS THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
TODAY.
GOOD MORNINGHI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MARCELLA GRAVES AND I AM
A CHUNK OF A WRITER ON THE
FRESNO CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND ALSO MEMBER
LOCAL.
FIVE TWO ONE AND I'M ALSO A
PROUD SUPPORTER OF AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND GOD BLESS THANK YOU.
I GOOD MORNING.
ALICE HELLO GUYS I AM A FAMILY
DAYCARE PROVIDER FROM FORTY
AVAIL INTEL ERIC COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING TULARE
THANK KINGS COUNTY FAMILY GET
PROVIDERS ASKING YOU JUST MIGHT
BE.
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS BARBARA
WILLIAMS I'M FROM CULT IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE BEEN A DAYCARE PROVIDE
FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING TODAY
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HOW ARE YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
YEAH.
MY DAUGHTER AND SHE'S ALSO PART
OF THE DAY ARE STILL -- MY NAME
IS PLEASED THAT REINA I'VE BEEN
A WRITER TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
I'M ALSO WERE FROM LOS BANOS.
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF YOU W. N.
C. C. P. U. AND I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
TODAY.
GOOD MORNING LADIES.
HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD MORNING GIRLS [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME SO WE
CROSSED THE ONE I'VE BEEN A-PROVIDER FOR TWENTY PLUS YEARS
FROM -- OF THE CENTRAL COAST TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OUT FROM SOME
BARBARA TO MERCED COUNTY.
AND I AM -- A MEMBER OF THE U.
D. W. C. C. P. U. AND I AM
PREPARED TO SUPPORT A. B.. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHARLIE NEAL AND I'VE
BEEN A PROVIDING SACRAMENTO FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND I SEN IN
SUPPORT OF THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
AND I'M REMEMBER A UT W. C. C.
P. U..
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MY NAME IS KIND OF
ANSWER WELL AND I HAVE BEEN A
DAY CARE PROVIDER. FOR TWENTY
SOMETHING YEARS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT SERVICE FOR
THE AND I SENATE SUPPORT THANK.
MY NAME IS RILEY.
MY NAME IS A GAME [inaudible]
MORNING.
I AM ELEVEN AM SIXTEEN I GREW UP
IN A DAYCARE AND I SENSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- HIGH --
MY NAME'S NOT ONLY KNOWS HOW
BEING IT AND CHILDCARE PROVIDER
AND TO SEE THEM OR SAY. FOR
NINETEEN YEARS AND I'VE ALSO
MEMBER FOR YOU D..
W. C. P. U. AND LASTING HERE
SUPPORT IN AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS EDITH
GUY ABEL'S IN I'VE BEEN THE
FAMILY CHAIR CARE PROVIDER IN
THE CITY OF SELMA FOR ONE YEAR.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF AS HE ARE
YOU LOCAL FIVE TWENTY ONE AND I
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT IN DEAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM OF LEARNING
MY NAME IS MADISON LE CONFESSED
I HAVE A I HAVE BEEN A FAMILY
SHELTER PROVIDED.
IN THE CITY A PARTIR. FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF A SEE YOU
LOCALS BY.
TWENTY ONE AND I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT AVIS AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
I WANT A MISSILE CIRCLE THIS I
YES THIS SYSTEM OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL LADY.
AND TING GIVE US FOR THE TIME IN
GOV LETS YOU CAN YOU HEAR FOR
SUPPORT IN OUR S..
WE KNOW YOU'RE SMART MAN.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ANY **** AND I'M FROM
ORVILLE I STAND IS SUPPORTIVE A.
B. YOU.
SEVEN EIGHT MORNING ALLEGE
WONDERFUL THE WHOLE STATE IS
REPRESENTED.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS COLONEL MARKS I'M ALSO
FROM OR BE OR BE ALL I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
W. LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND
BUTTE COUNTY REPRESENTED TO YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS HORSE TURNER -- PROVIDER
HERE IN PATTERSON CALIFORNIA --
FOR THE LAST TWELVE YEARS ALSO
SEND HERE TODAY AS A MEMBER OF
UT WCC P. YOU.
ALSO STRONG SUPPORTER FOR AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YES.
MY NAME IS ALI BABA I COME FROM
A PARTY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN WITH MY WIFE AND I
SUPPORTER.
AB THREE SEVENTY THANK YOU.
ALUMINUM IS MINE WHEN I IS THE
VEHICLE THEY POLITICAL FOR ME.
TO GO OUT OF MY ENEMIES PLUS THE
COST OF A LOT OF POLICIES MISSUS
UP IN THIS.
BATTLE IS THE MOST LIKELY BUT UP
A YELLOW LE LET YOU HAVE IT.
AT THIS OF THE THEATER YES YES
WHAT IS GOOD JOBS.
THANK YOU.
WEBER THEY ASK ME CALIFORNIANS
TRUCKS FOR THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH US YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MOLLY BYNUM YOU W. ASKED ME
THIRTY NINE THIRTY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS BLANKA GO DEAN AS
I'VE BEEN A TEACHER AND GLENN
COUNTY FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER FOR BOTH
GLENN AND YOU COUNTY. FOR MANY
YEARS AND I STAND HERE WITH
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM.
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ALEXANDER
GOOD DNS -- I AM HERE WHICH ARE
CARE PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT OF
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUCY VETERANS.
IN.
I ENJOYED TO GET EVEN.
BUT I WAS OF AB CITY MANY YEARS
CIRCLING TRENCHES AND BY ANY
BACK SO I CAN WITH THE SUPPORT
OF THE CHILD -- SO MY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING THIS
MORNING [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WHEN MATHIS WITH A U. D. W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU?
MORNING GOOD MY NAME S KIM
MARTIN AND I'M BEEN A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN NORTH
HOLLYWOOD FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
I'M HERE WITH CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO WONDERFUL PEOPLE MY NAME
IS GERALDINE STEVENS GONZALEZ
AND I HAVE BEEN A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER FOR OVER SIXTEEN YEARS.
IN LONG BEACH AND IN PALMDALE
AND NOW I'M HERE WITH THE UNION
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM REVIEW GUIDE
DOMESTIC WORKERS SB THIRTY NINE
THIRTY AND I SPEND SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ARE SEVEN RODRIGUEZ AND
I HAVE BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA FOR ONE YEAR.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED I FOUND HER
TODAY TO SUPPORT AB THREE SEVEN
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU VERY
MUCH.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
BEVERLY MOODY I AM A FAMILY CHAU
PROVIDER AND HAVE BEEN IN
LANCASTER. FOR TWELVE YEARS AND
A TEACHER AT SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I AM HERE -- FOR THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS YOU UNITED ALSO AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO THIS
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING HELLO MY NAME IS
TANYA MCMILLAN I'M A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN THE CITY
OF BELLFLOWER HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING CHILDCARE FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND I AM A MEMBER OF C. C. P.
UTAH CARE PROVIDED YOU NINE AND
ASK THEM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING ON I AM COMMITTEES
WITH EARLY AGE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEN WEIGHING ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING HIGH AND DRY RIVERA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ADAM
GRAY NAM POSH COUNTY CO CHAIR
[inaudible]
I BORN DO YOU W. -- ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM THAT MINING
MY NAME IS GLORIA I'M WOULD YOU
THE W. AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT
AB. SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THAT DAVE
MISSED.
I THINK WE GOT EVERYONE THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE TODAY I KNOW YOU TRAVELED A
LONG DISTANCE IN.
IS NOT EASY TO DO THAT --
ESPECIALLY TODAY AND BUT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL IT'S A NICE
STORE IT FILLED.
AND AND I THINK IT'S SIGNIFICANT
THAT YOU TRAVEL FROM ALL OVER
THE STATE TO TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS WITH US TODAY SO THANK
YOU IT'S VERY VERY POWERFUL WHEN
YOU DO THAT THAT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THIS LEGISLATION SEE NO ONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
YEAH HEY WE'RE UNION AGAIN.
WE HAVE THIS TIME WE THINK WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SOME PROGRESS I
WOULD BE INTERESTED IF YOU COULD
SHARE WITH US.
HOW YOU SEE THE THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDER WORLD CHANGING?
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL.
SURE ALL STAR EVENT ONE OF THE
EIGHT THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS NO CHILD CARE WITHOUT A
CHILD CARE WORKER.
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
NEED OF CHILD CARE FOR OUR STATE
WHICH WE KNOW IS.
REALLY SOMETHING THAT I'M ALL OF
CALIFORNIA NEEDS WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TO ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE
WORKERS IT IS NOT OKAY FOR
WORKERS TO BE PAID.
LESS THAN WHAT A FAST FOOD
WORKER MAKES IT IS NOT OKAY FOR
WORKER TO BE PAID LESS THAN WHAT
MINIMUM WAGE WITH.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING FOR SO WE SEE A
STRONGER WORKFORCE THAT WILL
HELP CHILD CARE ALTOGETHER WE
SEE IT -- A WORK FORCE THAT
REALLY CAN BECOME A PROFESSION
WHERE THOSE WHO SERVE WILL NOT
BE USING THE SAME SUBSIDIES --
OF THE STUDENTS THAT THEY SEE IN
ARE THE KIDS THAT THEY SEE IN
THE CHILD CARE SPACE OF THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT STRENGTHENING THE
WORKER WHICH IN TURN STRENGTHENS
CHILD KERR ALTOGETHER IN
CALIFORNIA.
COULD YOU.
COULD YOU GOING HELLO YEAH SO I
THINK THERE'S A THIRD PARTY ON
ERROR ON BEHALF OF YOUR D. W. AN
S. C. ARE YOU.
THERE THERE SEEMS TO BE A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
A QUE RIGHT WAGES ARMED
REGARDING BENEFITS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT TO THE PEOPLE CAN TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES -- AND
THERE'S ALSO A RELATIONSHIP TO
THE QUALITY OF CARE THAT'S
PROVIDED OKAY -- A YOUNG TO IN
THAT LINKS TO THE TRAINING THAT
WORKERS ARE PROVIDED.
AND RIGHT NOW I'M WORKERS HAVE
VERY LITTLE ACCESS TO TRAINING
EXCEPT THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO MEET IN ORDER
TO GET A LICENSE FOR EXAMPLE ALL
RIGHT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
REQUIRING NOW THAT THERE BE MORE
TRAINING NOT ONLY FOR LICENSED
PROVIDERS THAT OFFER FROM WHAT
ALSO FOR WHAT WE CALL LICENSE
EXEMPT PROVIDERS WHICH ARE
FAMILY FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
VERY CLEARLY SAYS PARENTS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHO TAKES
CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
RIGHT WHEN I DON'T GET THE RIGHT
TO TELL THEM WHO THAT IS THEY
GET TO CHOOSE AND SO WE PROVIDE
A MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM AS WE CALL
IT.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
RIGHT IN RECOGNIZING THE VALUE
OF THE PROVIDER OF THE PEOPLE
WHO PROVIDE THE CARE?
IS ALSO TO SAY RIGHT THROUGH WE
HOPE A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT RIGHT BECAUSE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS ALL
ABOUT EVERYBODY IT'S ABOUT
RESPECT.
IT'S ABOUT COMING TO THE TABLE
I'M AS EQUAL AS YOU CAN COM
ALRIGHT GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
STATE PAYS SUBSIDY ALL RIGHT.
BUT IT'S OUT OF RESPECT THAT YOU
SIT AND HAVE A CONVERSATION SO
THAT YOU HOPEFULLY CAN MUTUALLY
AGREED TO WHAT ARE WHAT ARE
APPROPRIATE WAGES RIGHT GIVEN
WITH IN THE THE GUIDELINES OF
THIS LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
WHATEVER IS AGREED TO IN A
MEMORANDUM UNDERSTANDING IS
GONNA COME BACK TO THIS.
LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVAL ALL
RIGHT -- BUT ALSO TO LOOK AT
WHAT ARE THE TRAINING NEED TO
THE PROVIDERS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY SEE AS THEIR
TRAINING NEEDS.
VERY FEW PEOPLE HAVE EVER BEEN
ASKED WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU NEED
IN ORDER TO BECOME -- AND PROVE
PROVIDER RIGHT SOMEBODY WHO
ACTUALLY HAS AND IT HAS A
BACKGROUND IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION HAS A CLUE TO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ALSO HAS A WAY OF
PROTECTING THEMSELVES ONE OF THE
THINGS THE UNIONS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN LATELY IS
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES.
BECAUSE WE'VE ALL BEEN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
KIDS RIGHT RIGHTFULLY SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO BE SURE
THAT THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY IS
PROTECTED WE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT THE WORKERS WHO PROVIDE THE
CARE OF THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
IS PROTECTED AS WELL AND SO
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
TRAINING. TO OUR PROVIDERS THEY
LOVE IT OKAY ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT THEY LOVE IT.
IS BECAUSE THEY LIKE TO BE
TRAINED BY THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE
WORK AS WELL AND SO THE USE CARE
TRAINERS THAT KIND OF THING SO
THEY'RE ALL KINDS OF IDEAS THAT
PROVIDERS HAVE THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN ASKED.
RIGHT WHAT DO THEY THINK SHOULD
HAPPEN HOW THEY THINK THEY
SHOULD BE TRAINED WHAT DO THEY
WANT RIGHT TO SOME OF THEM.
JUST WANT TO HAVE JUST WANT TO
HAVE THE VERY BASIC TRAINING
OKAY OTHERS WANT TO HAVE
POSSIBLY IN A A DEGREE SOME
PEOPLE WANT TO GO WANT TO BE A
HAVE A BACHELOR'S RIGHT AS ART
YES OUR PRINTER TESTIFIED -- BUT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ASKED THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY WE BELIEVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
CONVERSATION. TO FIND OUT WHAT
THE PROVIDERS THINK THAT THEY
NEED.
I'M ALSO AT THE SAME TIME TO
REALIZE WE HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO
THE CHILDREN AND THE FAMILIES
THAT WE I'D SERVICES.
TO AND WE HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO
THE PUBLIC IN REGARDS TO
WHATEVER LEGISLATION IS PASSED
WHAT YOU ALL THINK OUR
REQUIREMENTS WELL.
SO BUT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT
IT'S ALL ABOUT IN THE END IS
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF CARE
FOR KIDS. TO MAKE THEM
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S THE KIND OF THE BOTTOM
LINE THAT I THINK WE'VE ALL BEEN
INVOLVED WITH FOR A LONG TIME.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT I WAS
HOPING MY ONLY OTHER QUESTION IS --
WE NEED TO PAY THERE'S BEEN A
SORT OF A CHICKEN AND EGG ISSUE
HERE -- SO WE'RE GONNA GET.
AND YOU KNOW I NOTED THAT EVERY.
CHILD CARE PROVIDER HERE THIS
WAS SMILING.
AND I WAS THINKING WHAT A
WELCOME.
THING WHEN YOU'RE BRINGING YOUR
KIDS TO CHILD CARE TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S.
WHO'S YOU KNOW WHO LOVES WHAT
THEY'RE DOING -- I WISH FOR ALL
OF US HERE.
WALKING WITH SMILES EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT DOESN'T
QUITE HAPPEN -- BUT SO WE ARE
GOING TO VALUE BY BY THIS
PROCESS CREATE GREATER VALUE TO
THE PEOPLE DOING THE SERVICES
AND GREATER VALUE TO THE
CHILDREN THROUGH TRAINING AND
AND RESPECT AS YOU SAY.
THE COST SO WE KNOW THAT
PROVIDING CHILDCARE TODAY
WHETHER IT'S SUBSIDIZED CARE OR
WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE'S PAYING
THEIR OWN CARE.
IS IT IS I WOULD SAY OWNERS BUT
IT IS CHALLENGING.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT YES INDEED THE COST
MAY GO UP BECAUSE YOU KNOW GOD
FORBID WE'RE GOING TO PAY THE?
PEOPLE ARE DOING THE JOB MORE
THAN SLAVE WAGES HOW DO WE
ADDRESS HOW DO YOU ENVISION US
ADDRESSING THAT PROBLEM GOING
FORWARD. ONE IS.
THIRTY ONE IT'S AN EASY QUESTION
I KNOW RIGHT RIGHT YEAH BECAUSE
THERE THERE ARE TWO ISSUES HERE
RIGHT ONE IS IS THE RATE MAKING
THE RATE STRUCTURE OKAY AND WE
HAVE A VERY COMPLICATED RATE
STRUCTURE THAT WE WILL GO INTO
TODAY BECAUSE I BECAUSE ALL YOU
DO WAS SCREAM.
AT US AND SAY YOU'VE GOT TO BE
JOKING THAT IS IT'S TOO
COMPLICATED FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
DO IT DO IT SIMPLER YOU WANT.
ME TO COMPLICATE WE MAKE ME MAD
YES NO.
RIGHT AND THERE'S A BILL MOVING
THROUGH THAT WE HOPE WILL
SIMPLIFY THAT RATE STRUCTURE
OKAY -- HAVING SAID THAT THOUGH
MORE MONEY IS NEEDED OKAY AND SO
THE QUESTION BECOMES AND NOT
ONLY DOES THE MORE MONEY NEED
FOR THE WAGES FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM.
WE HAVE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIES AND ARE
NOT RECEIVING THEM.
OKAY WE'RE NOT EVEN I'M NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT UNIVERSALITY FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION I'M
JUST TALKING ABOUT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WHO WHO WHO IF THERE
WAS ENOUGH MONEY.
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIES
TODAY THAT MEANS OF THEIR
FAMILIES ARE EITHER STRUGGLING
THERE EITHER NOT WORKING OKAY
WHEN THEY COULD BE WORKING.
OR THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS OR THEY HAVE
THEIR GRANDPARENTS OR THEY HAVE
A FRIEND OR WHATEVER.
CHILDREN ARE AT HOME ALONE RIGHT
THE TERM THAT WE'VE USED FOR
YEARS AS LATCHKEY KIDS.
THAT'S A VERY DANGEROUS
PROPOSITION -- RIGHT WHEN YOU
HAVE CHILDREN STAYING AT HOME BY
THEMSELVES.
I'M I DON'T WANT TO USE THE
ANALOGY BUT WE JUST BEEN READING
ABOUT IN THE NEWSPAPERS OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE IMMIGRANT
CENTER IN.
TEXAS ARE.
BUT IT IS A PRETTY GOOD ANALOGY
OF KIDS TAKING CARE OF KIDS OKAY.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT IN IN THE UNION
CERTAINLY IS INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF YOU
ABOUT.
WE WILL AT SOME POINT ARE GOING
TO NEED A PERMANENT REVENUE
STREAM YOU CAN'T KEEP DOING THIS.
BECAUSE YOU'RE PAYING FOR THIS
IN THE END I MEAN DR PANOS AS I
HEAR TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE
TIME.
IN THAT WHAT YOU DON'T DO AN
EASY IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION YOU PAY FOR DOWN THE
ROAD OKAY YOU FIRST OF ALL HAVE
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER WHO SAYS
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE I HAVE TEN
KIDS THAT ARE.
READY TO READ AND I'VE GOT YOU
KNOW TEN OTHER KIDS WHO CAN
BARELY YOU KNOW PUT IT TOGETHER
RIGHT AND SO SHE OR HE MOSTLY
SHE IS SITTING THERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FASHION.
LESSON PLANS FOR TWO VERY
DISTINCT GROUPS OF KIDS ARE
RIGHT TO BY THE THIRD GRADE YOU
ALL HEARD THIS RIGHT IF THEY
AREN'T READING.
WE HAVE ISSUES OKAY AND SO.
IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DECIDE AS A SOCIETY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS BUT BUT
IT THIS IS THE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS ONE OF THE FIRST
STEPS RIGHT IS HEARING FROM THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE THAT
CARE.
WHAT DO THEY THINK IS NEEDED IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
WHAT THEY DELIVER TO THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM?
THANK YOU THAT'S JUST WHAT I
WANTED.
TO THANKS AND HAVE BEEN.
THANK YOU WELL -- FIRST BY ONE
THANK YOU BRING THIS BILL FORD.
HE JUST MADE ONE MY POINTS FOR
ME -- ANY THIS REALLY.
YEAH YEAH WELL I MEAN IT'S IT'S
IT'S A REALLY QUESTION OF VALUE.
RIGHT SO WE TALK ABOUT THE COST
BUT WE DON'T SPEND MUCH TIME
TALKING ABOUT THE VALUE AND
VALUE TO US AND ALSO -- MAKE
NOTE THAT -- THE ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH TO CHILD CARE WORK IS ARE
WORKING AND IS THE ENVIRONMENT
ARE YOUNG TOLD.
THE SAME ENVIRONMENT SO -- WE
NEED TO EMPOWER THE PEOPLE ARE
TAKING CARE OF OUR CHILDREN THEY
ARE OUR CHILDREN AFTER ALL -- TO
BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THOSE CHILDREN AND THEMSELVES
BECAUSE IT IS THE SAME IT'S NOT
A SELFISH JUST FOR ME IT'S THE
SAME ENVIRONMENT THE KIDS ARE
AND AND SO -- I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT TEST MAN'S BILLS ARE
JUST SIMPLY SAY I'D LIKE TO MOVE
TO BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME AND
LOOKING.
FOR TO MAKE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR VAN
SENATOR MITCHELL I WOULD JUST
SAY IN RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT AFFORDABILITY YOU KNOW --
WE AS A BODY -- WHEN IT COMES TO
K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION DON'T ASK
ABOUT HOW WE GOING TO PAY FOR IT
YOU JUST GET IT DONE BECAUSE WE
WANT TO BE COMPETITIVE?
AND WE FIXATE ON WHAT OUR
RANKING IS IN PER PUPIL SPENDING
IN CASE.
TO FOURTEEN AND EARLY CAN
EDUCATION SHOULD BE NO DIFFERENT.
ARE THEY THE SAME KIDS JUST TWO
YEARS LATER. FOR SURE THREE AND
EARLY CAN EDUCATION THEN YOU'RE
FIVE IN KINDERGARTEN IT'S THE
SAME TRIAL TWO YEARS LATER.
AND SO WHEN WE DECIDED TO
PRIORITY THEN WE WON'T EVEN HAVE
TO ASK OURSELVES THAT -- ANDAND
PERHAPS WITH THIS BILL AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS BEING ABLE TO
ORGANIZE AND THEY WILL HAVE THE
SAME -- POWER IF YOU WILL --
THAT THOSE WHO -- PROTECT K.
FOURTEEN EDUCATION.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THE OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
WELL I IN THIS IS A A WONDERFUL
DAY AND HISTORIC AS I MENTIONED
IN AND AND REALLY A BOLD MOVE
THAT ITS TIME HAS COME AGAIN.
AND WE WILL SEE THE SUCCESS OF
IT TODAY I BELIEVE AND AS IT
MOVES FORWARD AND AND THE
WINNERS AS HAS BEEN.
MENTIONED ARE OUR CHILDREN AND
WE NEED THAT.
WE NEED THAT SUCCESS WE NEED THE
BEST.
PROVIDERS POSSIBLE AND THIS WILL
ENABLE US TO HAVE THAT THAT OUR
CHILDREN WILL THRIVE NOT JUST.
FOR THIS GENERATION THE NEXT
GENERATION WITH THOSE
GENERATIONS WILL NEVER KNOW.
WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS SO.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT THEN THE
HAPPY TO TO TO MOVE FRWARD WE
DO HAVE A MOTION FROM -- SENATOR
PAN WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHYSICAL.
XIN IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO TO
SHARE COMMITTEE CENTER HILL HI.
I'M MORRELL.
WORLDNOW JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE PAN.
AYE.
IT'S FOUR VOTES THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
WELL WE WILL MOVE NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE A. B. FIVE TWENTY
NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVALS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING. TO MAKE IT.
GOOD MORNING MORNING SO WE ARE
AT THE AB FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE PROCEED I THINK -- SURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RIGHT
THERE NO SENATORS.
AB FIVE TWO NINE PROHIBITS THE
PRACTICE OF IMPOSING ON THE SPOT
MANAGED.
TIME OF ANY PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN ARE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN THE SYSTEM WORKING AT
A STATE HOSPITAL.
ONYX STAFFING ISSUES AND OUR
STATE HOSPITALS HAVE SUBJECTED
STAFF TO WORKING MANDATORY
OVERTIME.
RESULTING IN BACK TO BACK EIGHT
OUR SHIPS CREATING HEALTH
HAZARDS FOR PATIENTS AND STAFF.
WHEN I SERVED AS A SALMON YOU
KNOW COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND CHAIRMAN I TOURED PATTON
STATE HOSPITAL?
I WALKED INTO THE AREA WHERE ALL
THE PATIENTS WERE AND WHAT I SAW
WAS A SINGLE LINE SEPARATING
PATIENTS FROM THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING THERE.
AND THE EMPLOYEES THERE WAS NO
WALL OR OR THE BARRIER THERE WAS
THERE.
I THINK I MAKE REFERENCE TO MY
VISIT TO PATTON STATE HOSPITAL
TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO PROVIDE.
EMPLOYEE SAFETY AT OUR STATE
HOSPITALS.
PUTTING A STOP TO FORCED
OVERTIME ON A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN NOT ONLY STRENGTHENS
EMPLOYEE SAFETY BUT ALSO ENSURES
PATIENTS RECEIVE PROPER CARE AND
ATTENTION.
WITHIN THAT VISIT WE SEEN HOW
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS A
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN
ASSISTANCE.
DEAL ARM IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THOSE INSIDE -- STATE HOSPITALS.
WE ALSO SEEN THE SAFETY
CONDITIONS THAT ARE THERE.
IN THIS ISSUE AS FAR AS
MANDATORY OVERTIME I BELIEVE
PUTS.
EMPLOYEES IN JEOPARDY BECAUSE OF
THE AREAS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
COGNIZANT OF YOUR SURROUNDINGS.
A WEEK LATER A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN WAS ATTACKED AT PENN
STATE HOSPITAL.
IS SEVERELY INJURED.
THE REASON WHY I BRING UP THE
MANDATORY OVERTIME.
IS BECAUSE IT'S A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF SITUATION RATHER THAN
DIFFERENT OTHER AREAS IN JOBS IN
DIFFERENT PLACES ARE GOING ON IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HERE WITHIN THE STATE --
HOSPITAL YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
BE COGNIZANT OF YOUR
SURROUNDINGS FOR YOUR OWN SAFETY.
AND SO IN THE END THE DAY OF
WORKING A FULL EIGHT HOUR SHIFT
AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO A
MANDATORY OVERTIME.
BUT THOSE COMPONENTS AROUND
THERE I THINK BRINGS VALIDITY TO
THE REASON THIS BILL IS MOVING
FORWARD AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS KOBE HAAS
ET REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AND SPONSOR OF AB
FIVE TWO NINE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MONEY HERE AND CENTERS ITS CITY
HALL AND THIS MORNING -- AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID MY NAME'S
KOBE PRESIDING I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE THE LARGEST
DIRECT LEVEL OF CARE PROVIDERS --
IN STATE HOSPITALS AND DEVELOP
MEMBERS DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
AB.
FIVE TWENTY NINE PROHIBITS
UTILIZING MANDATORY OVERTIME.
AS A STAFFING POOL SO SAY YOU
WORK YOUR EIGHT HOUR SHIFT YOU.
YOU GET UP IN THE A AND GET TO
WORK AT SIX FORTY FIVE YOU'RE
ABOUT READY STEP OUT THE DOOR AT
TWO FORTY FIVE AND YOUR
SUPERVISOR TAPS YOU ON THE
SHOULDER.
AND SAYS I'M GONNA NEED YOU TO
WORK IN ANOTHER EIGHT HOUR SHIFT.
NOW THINK ABOUT YOUR SINGLE MOM.
AND YOU HAVE TWO KIDS AND YOU
GOT TO PICK THEM UP FROM SCHOOL
AT THREE FIFTEEN YOU DON'T HAVE
CHILDCARE ARRANGED YOU DON'T
HAVE SOMEBODY TO WATCH THEM.
UNTIL ELEVEN O'CLOCK WHEN YOU'RE
GONNA GET OFF WORK.
THIS IS AFFECTED BILLION DENTURE
SERVER KEEP BECAUSE IF YOU SAY
NO.
THE STATE WILL THEN ISSUE AN
ADVERSE ACTION.
AND THAT CAN AFFECT YOUR CAREER.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN IN GENERAL BUT AS AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID IN
TERMS OF SAFETY. 92%.
OF THE PATIENTS RESIDING IN THE
STATE HOSPITALS ARE THERE AND
FRIENDS A COMMITMENTS THAT MEANS
THEY'RE EITHER NOT GUILTY BY
REASON OF INSANITY.
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL OR
THEY'RE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS THEY JUST HAVE NOT
BEEN ADJUDICATED.
AS GUILTY YET [inaudible]
SO.
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
MENTION IS THE LAST YEAR THERE
WAS TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
ASSAULTS ON STAFF IN THE STATE.
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS WORKING IN THE SAY
HOSPITAL SYSTEM AT FIVE
HOSPITALS.
SO IT'S REALLY NOT A MATTER IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GET ASSAULTED
IT'S A MATTER WHEN AND HOW
SEVERE.
SO.
YOU REALLY TRULY DO NEED TO BE
ALERT AND ON YOUR TOES AT ALL
TIMES -- THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AS ACCURATELY SEATED
IN IN THE ANALYSIS DID A STUDY
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE STATED IN ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
SEVEN SHOULD SET A TARGET OF
REDUCING.
OVERTIME FOR NURSING STAFF
WORKING IN THE STATE HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH CARE FOR CITIES.
FACILITIES BY 50%.
BY TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SHOULD ELIMINATE
THE USE OF MANDATORY OVERTIME
EXCEPT IN DOCUMENTED AND
EMERGENCY -- YEAH FOR FOR US WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT STATEMENT
FOR THE LITTLE OVER COMMISSION
TO MAKE.
AS OF TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE WAS ONE POINT TWO
MILLION HOURS OF OVERTIME WORKED
IN THE STATE HOSPITALS BY PSYCH
TAX.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOURS INVOLUNTARY MEANING
MANDATORY.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO CONCLUDE BY
SAYING THAT I WANTED TO THANK
SENATORS.
MITCHELL JACKSON PAN AND HILL
FOR SUPPORTING IT SB SEVEN
EIGHTY WHEN IT CAME BEFORE YOU
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE HOPE TO
HAVE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDING
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR EMBERS RAINED SHERMAN WITH
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALTHOUGH THIS LEGISLATION DOES
NOT IMPACT OUR MEMBERS CORRECTLY
WE BELIEVE -- IT'LL HELP TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY --
SURROUNDING THE FACILITIES AND
OUR MEMBERS HAVE GONE THROUGH
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR OVER THE
YEARS OF BEING FORCED WORK
OVERTIME AND SO WE KNOW HOW.
IMAGINE YOU CAN BE TO THE SAFETY
OF THE FACILITY AND PUBLIC SO.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THE BILL ME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR MITCHELL.
I HAVE A QUESTION I CAN YOU KNOW
TO TO REQUIRE MANDATORY OVERTIME
SUGGESTS TO ME A STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM AND SO AND SO HOW MANY
VACANCIES ARE IN THE POSITION
AND WHAT.
PLAN.
WOULD BE AN ASSET THE LAST
MINUTE. TO THE DEGREE THAT WE
HAVE TO GET A BILL TO PROTECT
THEM FROM THAT THIS SUGGESTS TO
ME THAT STAFF IS INADEQUATE SO
WHERE ARE WE IN THAT PROCESS.
SO CERTAIN FACILITIES HAVE A
MORE DIFFICULT THAN OTHERS LIKE
ATASCADERO AND COOLING TO HAVE A
VERY TOUGH TIME -- THIS IS.
STAFFING THEIR FACILITIES
HOWEVER THEY'RE NOT THE FACILITY
THAT HAS THE LARGEST AMOUNT OVER
TIME.
PATTON'S AND PATENTS VACANCY
RATE IS 4% [inaudible]
WHILE ATASCADERO.
AN ACTUAL SHOULD SAY THE LARGEST
VACANCY RATE IS AT METRO.
AT 19%.
THAT'S JUST BECAUSE YOU
AUTHORIZED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOUR NEW
POSITIONS THERE BY HIS HAND
ENABLES.
THEY JUST HAVEN'T THEY'VE
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF BUT
STAFF STAFFING IN THE LA AREA IS
VERY EASY.
STAFFING ON THE CENTRAL COAST IS
VERY HARD WHERE IT'S INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE -- AND SO FORTH -- AND
THEN CENTRAL VALLEY LET BUT IN
THOSE AREAS WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT
TO STAFF THEY'RE NOT HAVING THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH OVER
TIME RIGHT SO ARE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH OVERTIME
RATES ARE AT NAPA STATE HOSPITAL.
AND AT PATTON STATE HOSPITAL
WHERE THE VACANCY RATES ARE
INCREDIBLY LOW IT'S BASED ON SO
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING THE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
I MEAN GRANTED THERE'S THERE'S
HIGH OVERTIME EVERYWHERE RIGHT
BUT THE MANDATORY OVERTIME IS
GENERALLY SEEN AT NAPA.
AND THAT'S A MANAGEMENT ISSUE
IT'S NOT AN ISSUE OF OKAY AND
AND AND AND I WOULD LIKE THAT I
THINK WHEN YOU.
ARE PLANNING EXACTLY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR FOR
AUTHORIZING THE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE NEW PSYCH TECH
POSITIONS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
THAT WILL VIRTUALLY ELIMINATE.
THE MANDATORY OVERTIME AND AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS PRACTICE SHOULD AND TO
BECAUSE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
A NURSE CANNOT WORK BEYOND
TWELVE HOURS IN A DAY.
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT THE STATE WAS
EXEMPTED FROM THAT WORK ORDER IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHICH WE DO
HAVE A MOTION OF PENDING FROM
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
OF OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU IN THIS IS THIS IS
MUCH NEEDED THEN DOES CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE FOR THOSE PATIENTS
IN THOSE.
WORKERS THAT -- THAT WE SERVE
THE ANSWER OF THOSE THOSE
PATIENTS IN THESE INSTITUTIONS
WITH THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING OF LIKE TO QUOTE.
SAYS REVIVAL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON -- THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL HI BILL I'M RALPH.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
AYE.
THE BILL HAS REVOKED IT'S ENOUGH
TO GET UP BUT WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION MOVING
OUT ITEM NUMBER.
SIX AB FIVE SIXTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO.
WELCOME ALL RIGHT YOUR REGULAR
HERE NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL BE BRIEF AT THAT
PLEASE THE CHAIR THAT WE FIND
CREATED THANK YOU -- AB -- FIVE
SIXTY WILL ENSURE THAT GREAT
PAIR DOLLARS ARE NOT USED BY
ANTILLES TO EITHER FAVOR.
OR WORK AGAINST -- UNIONIZATION
AND WITH ME I HAVE ONE WITNESS
ON MISTER MOM AGAIN.
VOTERS TO TEAR MEMBERS MIKE
MULLIGAN HALF THE COALITION'S
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
PROTECTING THE RATE PAYERS FROM.
THE USE OF FUNDS THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE.
FOR UTILITIES YES WE ARE BOTH
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
IT WAS IT WAS IT WAS.
GOOD TO SEE THIS BILL LAST WEEK
IN -- ENERGY AND UTILITIES AND
IT WAS A GOOD BILL THEN AND IT'S
A GOOD BILL TODAY WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SENATOR JACKSON'S IN
NO OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE.
AYE MORRELL.
NO JACKSON ALL RIGHT JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I CAN.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES ENOUGH
TO GET UP TO HOLD THE ROLL OVER
FOR THE OPTION MEMBER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA I SAW A
MINUTE AGO IS HE NOT HERE.
RIGHT WE WILL.
WAIT FOR A OTHER AUTHOR.
WHAT WE CAN DO SINCE WE HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES WE DO IF WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB THREE FOURTEEN AND
A VOTE?
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION ON AB -- THREE FOURTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR HILL HI.
I'M MARA.
BROWN NO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
I PAN.
YOU'RE THE VOTE THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTES BUT WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COVER WELCOME.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS WILL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER SEVEN DOES THAT
WORK FOR YOU AB -- SIX TWENTY
FIVE S. PERFECT.
RIGHT.
WHEN YOU ARE READY AND
COMFORTABLE?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M PROUD
VISITS SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WEEKS
WHICH EXTENDS THE EMPLOYEE
RETENTION 10% BIG PREFERENCE.
TWELVE PUBLIC CONTRACTS WHAT
ABOUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE 10% BID PREFERENCE A SCORING
CREDIT ON THE STATE DID FOR
TRANSIT OPT FOR A TRANSIT
OPERATOR.
THAT VOLUNTARY AGREES RETAIN THE
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES THE PREVIOUS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO BE THE SAME
AS ON THE PREVIOUS CONTRACTOR.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
LEGISLATION WAS SIGNED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE TO PROVIDE A 10%.
FRIENDS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PUBLIC TRANSIT CONTRACTS
PROVIDERS THAT VOLUNTARILY
AGREED TO RETAIN THE QUALIFIED
EMPLOYEES THE PREVIOUS
CONTRACTOR.
IT'S ABOUT LAW IT WAS TO ADDRESS
THE HIGH RATE OF TURNOVER
OCCURRING IN THE CONTRACTED OUT
SEGMENT A PUBLIC TRANSIT.
HOWEVER THAT LEGISLATION TO NOT
PROVIDE A BIDDING PREFERENCE FOR
BIDDERS ON STATE CONTRACTS AND
PUBLIC TRANSIT WHO AGREED TO
RETAIN EXISTING EMPLOYEES.
THE STATE TRANSIT WORKER WORKERS
JOBS RIGHT REST DUE TO
CONTRACTING OUT FOR EXAMPLE
STATE EMPLOYEES WERE SHUTTLE
DRIVERS ARE HEARST CASTLE LOST
THEIR JOBS -- CONTRACTOR CAME
AND HAD A BIG PROFITS BEEN IN
PLACE PROSPECTIVE CONTRACTOR
WOULD HAVE OULD HAVE BEEN IN SO
I WOULD HAVE HAD AN INCENTIVE TO
KEEP THE DRIVERS AND THE DRIVERS
WILL LIKELY.
STILL BE WORKING TODAY.
WE MUST ACT PREVENT UNNECESSARY
AND COSTLY TRANSIT WORKER
LAYOFFS -- THIS MEASURE HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
AND WOULD BE A SHAME GUSTO THE
TEAMSTERS PROVIDE FOR THE TEST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
ALSO THE INLAND BOATMEN.
UNION.
BOTH OF THOSE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL -- WE SPONSORED THE TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE VERSION THAT
ONLY APPLIED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
AND AND THAT BILL AS A SIMILAR
KALRA SAID WAS BECAUSE WE HAD
THIS TRAINING OF EMPLOYEES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- WHERE THEY
WOULD LOSE THEIR JOBS EVERY
THREE YEARS BECAUSE A NEW
TRANSIT CONTRACTOR WOULD COME IN
AND UNDER BID?
BASED BASICALLY ON ON EMPLOYEE
WAGES.
SO THIS TAKES THAT INCENTIVE
AWAY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S
WORKED VERY VERY WELL WE BIRD
HEARING NO COMPLAINTS FROM
TRANSIT EMPLOYERS -- AND IT IT
HAS REALLY PROVIDE STABILITY FOR
THE FOR THE WORK FORCE AND SO
NOW IT'S TIME TO TO MOVE IT TO
THE STATE LEVEL THERE ARE
CONTRACTS AT THE STATE LEVEL
WHERE THIS.
OCCURS AND AND WE NEED TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES AS WELL SO
WE PUT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THE MORNING.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S ROBERT ESTRADA I AM
THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
INLAND BOWMAN'S UNION AND WE ARE
CO SPONSORS TO THIS BILL.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO PUT THE
THE THE PERSONAL TOUCH ON IT
THAT FOR US THIS IS NEITHER --
HYPOTHETICAL LOOKING BACKWARDS
OR FORWARDS -- THE IN THE PAST
WE'VE EXPERIENCE SOMETHING VERY
PARALLEL TO THE SOLO ON A
FEDERAL BASIS BUT ALCATRAZ.
WE HAD A NEW CONTRACTOR COME IN.
GAME THE CONTRACT WITH THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE WHICH WE
HAD HAD SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO AND WE HAD WORKERS WITH
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE.
THAT WERE SHOVED ASIDE --
BECAUSE IT WAS NO PROTECTION AT
THAT TIME.
FOLLOWING ON FROM THAT THE WORD
THEIR SERIES OF INCIDENTS
INCLUDING -- MULTIPLE SUITS
BILLS IN THE BAY AND OTHER
ISSUES THAT.
THAT PUBLIC SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT BEYOND JUST THE THE
EMPLOYEE'S OURSELVES.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD WE HAVE A
CONTRACT COMING UP ANGEL ISLAND
STATE FERRY AND THAT SORT OF
THIS IS OUR IMMEDIATE.
THAT'S INTERMEDIATE SITES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THAT AND PROVIDE THE THE
LONGSTANDING PROFESSIONALISM
SHOULD REALLY HAVE.
SOME CONSIDERATION IN THIS
PROCESS AND AND AND CONSIDERING
THAT WHAT'S HAPPENED SINCE WITH
THE FEDERAL LAW SINCE ALCATRAZ
WAS LOST. FOR OUR MEMBERS NOW
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS IN THERE
THAT OUT RIGHT THAT THOSE
WORKERS NOW HAVE TO BE.
PROTECTED SO OUR PEOPLE GOT
BUMPED OUT IF WE WERE TO COME
BACK AND WE CAN BUMP IN THOSE
SAME EMPLOYEES ARE THERE AND YOU
KNOW IN THE BOTTOM LINE WE'RE
OKAY WITH THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT UNIONS ARE ABOUT AND WE
WANT TO PROTECT WORKERS AND GIVE
THEM EVERY.
POSSIBLE LEG UP SPECIALLY WHEN
IT REPRESENTS THE MOST
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE SO WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAM CHAIRMAN HILL
AND ALL TE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEE SAND
ALL -- I'M WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
WAREHOUSE UNION.AND THE I. B. U. IS ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
WAREHOUSE YOU.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS-LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
HERE IN OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FOR SENATOR JACKSON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THAT FASTER NINE
VERY GOOD.
VERY GOOD BILL AND THANKS GOOD
SENSE.
I MIGHT INDICATE MY STAFF IS
REMINDED ME I VOTED FOR THE
IDENTICAL BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE AND IN
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TOP.
THREE SYSTEM RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL.
NO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL ALL RIGHT
MITCHELL.
DOES HAVE THREE VOTES BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLLOVER FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B..
SIX FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISS SURE OF THE UP TO
PRESENT AB SIX FORTY SEVEN FORTY
TODAY.
SB SIX FORTY SEVEN REQUIRE
COSMETIC AND DISINFECTED
MANUFACTURERS WHO ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW. TO
POSE THE SAFETY DATA SHEETS
ONLINE AND TRANSLATE INTO COMMON
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY SOMEONE
SPECIALS.
SALON PROFESSIONALS MANY OF WHOM
ARE IN IMMIGRANTS WOMEN OF COLOR
AND HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH SKILLS.
ARE EXPOSED THE BEAUTY CARE
PRODUCTS CONTAINING A MULTITUDE
OF CHEMICALS KNOWN OR SUSPECTED
OF PRESSING CAUSE HARM.
REQUIRING SAVE IT AS A DATA
SHEETS BE ACCESSIBLE ONLINE IN
TRANSIT INTO LANGUAGES CALMLY
SPOKEN BY SOME FASHIONS WILL
RAISE AWARENESS TO APPROVE THE
HEALTH.
AND WORKING CONDITIONS OF THE
WORKERS AS WELL AS THE THE
CUSTOMERS.
AND DISCUSSES THE OPPONENTS OF
AGREED PROPOSED TECHNO
AMENDMENTS. THIRTY TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS.
WHICH OF AN OUTLINED IN THE NOW
SAYS THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION.
I WOULD BE DELAYED BY SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS CATHERINE PORTER OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING -- AGAIN I'M CATHERINE
PORTER I'M POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL
SALON COLLABORATIVE.
WORK COALITION WHICH WORKS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH SAFETY AND
RIGHTS FOR THE PREDOMINANTLY
VIETNAMESE IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE
AND NAIL SALONS.
WE AND WORK SAFE ON WHOSE BEHALF
BY ALSO SPEAK TODAY ARE CO
SPONSORS OF A. B..
SIX FOUR SEVEN CALIFORNIA NAIL
IN HERE SO LONG WORKERS MANY OF
WHOM ARE OF OUR WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
HANDLE A RANGE OF DISINFECTANTS
AND COSMETIC PRODUCTS CONTAINING
PERSONAGENS AND CHEMICALS LINKED
TO REPRODUCTIVE RESPIRATORY AND
OTHER HARM.
MANY SALON PROFESSIONALS ARE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
UNDER EXISTING LAW MANUFACTURES
MUST DEVELOP AND DISTRIBUTE HARD
COPY SAFETY DATA SHEETS FOR
PRODUCTS CONTAINING HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES.
THEY ARE ALTERNATELY REQUIRED TO
BE AVAILABLE AT WORKPLACES.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THESE HARD
COPY DOCUMENTS CAN GET LOST IN
THE LONG CHAIN OF DISTRIBUTION.
SALON OWNERS REPORTS OF THEIR
OFTEN NOT AVAILABLE AT BEAUTY
SUPPLY STORES.
ADVOCATES LIKE OUR ORGANIZATION
AND COUNTY AND CITY COORDINATORS
OF LOKI LOCAL HEALTH EMAIL
SOMEONE RECOGNITION BROWN'S.
REPORTED THEY HAVE A HARD TIME
OBTAINING SAFETY DATA SHEETS
FROM MANUFACTURERS AS THEY TRY
TO ASSIST SALONS AND BECOMING
HEALTHIER WORKPLACES.
EVEN IF AN SDS IS AVAILABLE
ONLINE SOMETIMES ONLY SOMEONE
WITH A PROFESSIONAL LICENSE CAN
ACCESS THEM.
THEN ONE SAFETY DATA SHEETS ARE
OBTAINED LAKE WHICH IS OFTEN A
BERRIER -- BECAUSE THEY
CURRENTLY ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
APPEAR IN ENGLISH.
SO AB SIX OR SEVEN ONLY REQUIRES
TWO THINGS OF MANUFACTURES ONE
WHERE BECAUSE MEDICAL
DISINFECTANT IS ALREADY REQUIRED
TO HAVE A SAFETY DATA SHEET.
THAT SAFETY DATA SHEET MUST BE
POSTED ONLINE AND TO MAKE SAFETY
DATA SHEETS MORE UNDERSTANDABLE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO USE THEM BY
TRANSLATING THEM ONLINE.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A MODEST AND
REASONABLE ATTEMPT TO SHINE MORE
LIGHT ON THE POTENTIAL HAZARDS
OF COSMETICS AND DISINFECTANTS.
USED EVERY DAY BY WOMEN SALON
WORKERS FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE A YES VOTE TODAY ON A BE
SIX OR SEVEN VERY GOOD THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THE CHAIRMAN MANY LEE ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNSELED NOT IN SUPPORT SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR COMING UP OUT OF
ORDER BUT WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE ON THE OFFICE
SPONSORED WHICH OF THE LETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHE THANK
YOU.
IF THE SPOTS HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING POSITIONS FOR OUR
SUCH RESPONSIBILITY BAY AREA
CHAPTER.
AS WELL AS BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP OUT FOR
THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUPIN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS AND
REMOVING THAT THE OPPOSITION I
THINK IT MAKES THINGS A LOT
EASIER. TO IS A GREAT BILL AND I
THINK IT'S NECESSARY IMPORTANT
THAT WE PROVIDE THAT IN OTHER
LANGUAGES.
YOU PLACE IT ONLINE SO THAT IT'S
USUALLY IN A RESERVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
VERY GOOD WE DO HAVE A MOTION
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR HAS AND TO THE
SENATORS -- AND I I DO WANT TO
THANK -- THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL MISLI FOR
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH MY
OFFICE WHILE THE SPONSORS.
I HAD TO FIND A COMPROMISE
POSITION ANNOUNCEMENTS OF MINE
THANK STAFF WAS VERY VERY
HELPFUL AND ALSO HELPING US
ACHIEVE THAT.
THANK YOU THAT IS A VAST NIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
THIS IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WELL THE ROLE SENATOR HILL AYE
HILL AYE MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE [inaudible]
I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE AFTER
MEMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR A
ANOTHER AUTHOR WOULD TO ANYONE
BACK TO AN ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FOR THIS CONSENT CALENDAR.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR
OBJECTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR HILL HI BILL I MORRELL
[inaudible]
I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE. FOR VOTERS IN WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FOR THE
ABSENT [inaudible]
MEMBER [inaudible]
ASH.
WE WILL TAKE A SLIGHT RECESS
UNTIL.
WE HAVE A MEMBER. 2%
[inaudible]
YEAH
TOOK OFF. SEVENTEEN CONDITIONS
TO CITIZENSHIP [inaudible]
DISCOVER.
WELL IT'S ACTUALLY ON MY WAY.
THEY WERE EASY YOU KNOW I MEAN
[inaudible]
OKAY OKAY [inaudible]
MICHAEL.
OKAY GO.
HARSH I NEVER HAD THE CHANCE.
YOU READY PERCENT SIR -- IT WAS
A CO
.
WE ARE THE SECURING THE HEARING
HAS RECONVENED.
GOOD MORNING WE ARE MOVING NOW.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN THIS AREA WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
SENATORS -- FOR SOME FOR MYSELF
HAPPY TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
THIS YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS BILL WILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
BOARDS OF CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
TO DIVEST PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT FUNDS FROM ANY
INVESTMENT VEHICLE OWNED BY THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY.
THE LIQUIDATION OF INVESTMENTS
IN TURKEY IS CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF A FEDERAL LAW.
ISSUING SANCTIONS AGAINST TURKEY
OR FAILING FOR FAILING TO
RECOGNIZE THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
THIS CONTINGENCY CLAUSE ENSURES
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY TO DIVEST
FROM HE REMAINS CONSISTENT WITH
PASSED THE VESTMENTS FROM
FOREIGN NATIONS INCLUDING SUDAN
AND IRAN.
IN THAT PRESENTS STIRS WILL NOT
DIVEST UNTIL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN ACTION
FIRST ALSO THIS BILL INCLUDES A
PROVISION PROTECTING THE BOARDS
OF CALPERS.
AND CAL STIRS BY STATING ACTIONS
TAKEN TO ALIGN WITH THIS BILL
ARE NOT REQUIRED IF THEY VIOLATE
THE PORTS FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITIES.
FURTHER THERE'S A PROVISION
INDEMNIFY AND THE BOARDS AND
EMPLOYEES FROM CLAIMS.
BROUGHT FORTH BY ACTIONS TAKEN
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THIS BILL.
THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE AND THEIR UNRELENTING
CAMPAIGN TO DENY THE GENOCIDE.
CONTINUES TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ARMENIANS WEEKS AND THE
SYRIANS WHO SUFFERED AT THE
HANDS OF THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT.
OTTOMAN GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS CLEAR POLICY ON
THE GENOCIDE.
AS DEMONSTRATED BY DECADES OF
LEGISLATIVE RESOLUTIONS AND GO
OVER TO TORRENT GUBERNATORIAL
PROCLAMATIONS.
ALLOWING PENSION PLANS TO
MAINTAIN HOLDINGS AND PUBLIC
TRUST.
THAT ARE.
THAT ARE TURKISH GOVERNMENT
BONDS INDIRECTLY SUBSIDIZES
TURKISH THE NILE OF THE GENOCIDE.
THIS BILL CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACT APPROPRIATELY
AGAINST COUNTRIES THAT HAVE A
RECORD OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY.
WITH ME IS ME RUN TO MY CHEN
WITH THE ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF
AMERICA.
THANK YOU.
WE'LL EMAIL [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- TERM HEALTH
BUT YOUR MORALE.
WE HAVE THE ARMY ASSEMBLY
AMERICA.
I THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF STATEMENT.
THE LETTERS AND MY OUR LETTER
SUPPORT OF COURSES ON RECORD.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY THIS THIS BILL
OF COURSE THIS IS THE SECOND
TIME.
AROUND FOR THIS BILL AND THE
WE'RE WE'RE VERY MUCH.
IN TUNE WITH WITH PRESIDENT.
DIE BESTEN PRESIDENT THAT THE
THAT TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
HAS HAS SAID AS SO WE MEMBERS
ARE IN.
MENTIONED THE WITH RESPECT TO
SOUTH AFRICA IN THE APARTHEID
REGIME.
OF THAT.
OF INITIATIVE WAS WAS -- LED BY
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER BY THEN
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH.
THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
CHAIR MAXINE WATERS -- AND THEY
GOT THEY GOT.
THE DIVESTMENT LEGISLATION
PASSED OVERWHELMINGLY.
AND THE THE UC SYSTEM ALSO ENDED
UP OF OF PASSING A YOU KNOW.
A SIMILAR -- YEAH RESOLUTIONS TO
DIVEST UC SYSTEM FUNDS FROM
SOUTH AFRICA AT THE TIME.
IT'S HAPPENED WITH WITH RESPECT
TO SUDAN AND IRAN.
WE'RE WE'RE FOLLOWING PRESIDENT --
THIS IS THIS IS YOU KNOW SO THIS
IS NOTHING NEW IN IT WITH WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BODY.
I ALSO WANTED TO EMPHASIZE.
IN OUR LETTER SUPPORT I I
MENTIONED THE THOUSANDS OVER THE
OVER THE YEARS SINCE.
CASTERS WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN CALPERS IN
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO THOUSANDS OF
ARMENIAN AMERICAN RETIREES.
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SPANNING BOTH PENSION SYSTEMS.
I WANT TO JUST MENTION ONE
EXAMPLE OF SUCH A SUCH A
WONDERFUL RETIREE EDWARD
MINASSIAN OF MORAGA CALIFORNIA.
HE TAUGHT. FOR THIRTY NINE YEARS
AT LANEY COLLEGE -- IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA PART OF THE FOR ALL
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
OF COURSE.
PART OF CAL STIRS -- HE ALSO
TAUGHT AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
HISTORY AND GOVERNMENT.
AND MINASSIAN NOT ONLY WAS IS AN
EXEMPLARY TEACHER AND THEY GOT
HE'S WITH US TO THIS DAY HIS
OLDER SIBLINGS WHO WERE BORN IN
THE OLD COUNTRY WERE KILLED
DURING THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
SO HE HE FEELS THAT HE FEE IS
FELT IT ON HIS OWN SKIN.
EVERY TIME WHEN HE WAS WITH HIS
PARENTS.
HE WOULD BE REMINDED OF IT.
HE WAS HE OF COURSE BORN HERE IN
THE US BUT HIS OLDER SIBLINGS.
DIDN'T MAKE IT ADMIN NOT SEEN IS
ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THIS THIS
SEMINAL BOOK.
ON THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE CALLED
MOUSA DOT IT'S BASED ON FRANCE
RIFFLES NOVEL THE FORTY DAYS AND
WE SAT DOWN AND IT'S ABOUT.
B. THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT
WORKING WITH THE US STATE
DEPARTMENT.
BACK IN THE NINETEEN THIRTIES
[inaudible]
SUCCESSFULLY WHITEWASHING.
A FILM BY MGM METRO GOLDWYN
MAYER THEY HAD ALREADY STARTED
PREPRODUCTION OF THE FILM BASED
ON FRANCE RUFFLES NOVEL.
EGGMAN NOW SEE AN EXPOSED.
HOW ESTHER THE TRADITION MASTER
THE TIME OR TWO GOON?
WAS WORKING.
HAND IN HAND WITH STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS IN ORDER TO
QUASH THIS SEMINAL FILM.
THAT MGM WAS READY TO DO INSTEAD
STARTED PREPRODUCTION.
ADMIN AUSTIN IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF THOUSANDS OF ARMENIAN
AMERICAN RETIREES.
OF AND PENSIONERS WHO WHO
BENEFIT IN WHO WHO GIVEN.
A LOT TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
A LOT TO THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WHO AND WHO BENEFIT OF COURSE
FROM CASA CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
INVESTMENTS?
IN VARIOUS -- ESTABLISHED
EMERGING MARKETS HOWEVER IN THIS
CASE WE BELIEVE WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT -- YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD NOT BE AIDING AND
ABETTING.
INVESTMENTS IN TURKISH
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED THAT
SECURITIES AND BONDS THAT IS A
REGIME THAT IS THE ERROR THAN
REGIME OF COURSE IS IS A BAD
ACTOR IN THE REGION.
AND WE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GOOD LARGEST COUNTY WE SHOULD
SEND A SIGNAL TO THAT REGIME.
WE WILL NOT HAVE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE TESTIMONY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SIT.
THE MORNING.
AIR SENATORS CHOICE ONLY
MARTINEZ WEIGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION.
OUR BOARD IS FIDUCIARY IS IS
TRYING TO FUND THE BENEFITS OF
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA AND ANY
TYPES OF RESTRICTIONS.
THEM IN A POSITION WHERE THEY
ARE HOPEFULLY IT WAS NOT AS
DIVERSIFIED AND THEY MAY HAVE
ISSUES WITH REACHING THAT GOAL
AND THAT'S ESPECIALLY.
IMPORTANT TO GET THERE -- AS WE
TRY TO REACH FOR FUNDING BY
TWENTY FORTY SIX UNDER THE PLAN
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND
RESPECTFUL POSITION.
THANK YOU SEE WHAT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
YOUR I HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
OPPOSITION IF I MAY TO THE CHAIR.
TO THE WHICH ANY EITHER ONE
WOULD YOU [inaudible]
WILLING [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
MY QUESTION IS I I APPRECIATE
YOU HAVE A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY -- TO TO THE
PENSIONERS BUT I'M I'M CURIOUS
AS TO WHETHER -- YOUR BOARD YOUR
GOVERNING ENTITY ESTABLISHES ANY
KIND OF BOTTOM LINE CRITERIA IN
TERMS OF INVESTMENTS THAT YOU
DEEM INAPPROPRIATE.
THE BOARD DOES LOOK AT
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
GOVERNANCE RESEARCH THEY HAVE AN
ESG POLICY AND THEY ALSO THE
DIVESTMENT POLICY BUT DIVESTMENT
AS ALWAYS LAST RESORT.
AND WHAT THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS THE
ECONOMIC RISK INVOLVED.
SO THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE TO FIND
AND HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES THAT
PROCESS INITIATE.
SO CAN BE INITIATED BY THE BOARD
SO THEY CAN ASK TO AND BUT THEY
ALWAYS START WITH ENGAGEMENTS.
AND CHRIS IS UNIQUE SITUATION
WITH A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
BUT THEY START WITH ENGAGEMENT
THEY WORK ON THE ISSUES THAT
THEY IDENTIFY THROUGH THE SG
PROCESS AND THEY USE PROXY
VOTING THEIR SHAREHOLDER POWER
IN THOSE SORT OF THINGS AND TRY
TO SEE WHERE THEY CAN GET ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED.
AND AGAIN AS A LAST RESORT
THERE'S NO ACTION -- CHANGE THAN
THEY COULD MOVE TO DIVEST.
AND HAS YOUR BOARD -- NISHIDA
PROCESS WITH REGARD TO THIS
ISSUE [inaudible]
NOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT.
YOU.
WE WOULD LIKE -- TO I'M SORRY
SENATOR MORALE LIKE EUROPE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH I SPOKEN AND SUPPORTED
NUMBER THANK YOU HAVE.
FOUR I BELIEVE TURKEY SHOULD.
ABSOLUTELY ACKNOWLEDGE HAD THE
GENOCIDE AND GOT SOME GOOD
FRIENDS THERE.
ARE FROM TURKEY AND THE HOUSTON
OVER THERE EVERY YEAR AND I
CAN'T GO ANYMORE BECAUSE THE
SEEM TO BE.
COMING MORE OF AN OPPRESSIVE
GOVERNMENT -- SO I CAN I JUST
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT'S WHERE MY
HEART IS ON THE APP BUT I'M A
LITTLE BIT RE IT LOCKED IN
ANYTIME -- YOU KNOW WE WE TRY TO
YOU KNOW CALPERS AND CAL STAR IS
IS A LITTLE BIT BEHIND ON THEIR
INVESTMENT SO.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE BEST
THING FOR YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A
DUTY -- TO INVESTOR SO IT'S KIND
OF A COMPLICATED THNG BUT ONE
OF THINGS I WORRY ABOUT WORK
COULD END UP GOING OF WHAT IF WE
HAVE STATES THAT -- THE IN A
LOUISIANA PRODUCES OIL ON YOU
KNOW I'M FOR OIL PRODUCTION OF
OIL -- WOULD WE HAVE SOMETHING
SOMEDAY THIS AS WELL HER SISTERS
CAM -- INVEST IN.
OIL IN LOUISIANA SO THOSE ARE
KIND OF THINGS AND I'M NOT EVEN
SURE I'M GOING TO VOTE ON AT THE
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE -- TOUGH ONES
BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS STOOD WITH
YOU OVER THE YEARS SINCE WE'VE
KNOWN EACH OTHER ON YES.
BUT THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT -- BECAUSE CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS IS THERE IS.
THERE BEHIND AND THEY NEED TO
CATCH UP SO THEY HAVE TO USE --
IS GOOD AS I CAN THEY THEY CAN'T.
AND I'M NOT SURE OF TURKEYS AT
THAT POINT [inaudible]
WHERE -- WE SHOULDN'T DO
BUSINESS WITH THEM -- AGAIN THEY
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE GENOCIDE
WHICH THEY NEVER HAVE SO ANYWAY
I JUST WANT EXPRESS MY OPINION
THERE.
AND IN.
YEAH JUST TO EXPRESS MY OPINION
I'M NOT SURE HOW TO VOTE ON AS
SOME.
STRUGGLING WITH RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOUR INSURANCE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO IN YOUR CLOTHES.
ESPECIALLY AMENDMENTS AND HOW
THEIR FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITIES
STILL MAINTAINED IN THAT.
THANK YOU AND DOES SHE KNOW
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
I HOPE I CAN CALL YOUR CONCERNS
AND YOU CAN COME TO A PLACE
WHERE YOU CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL
SENATOR.
FIRST OF ALL I'VE.
AS A CALIFORNIAN FIRST AND
FOREMOST I NEVER WANT TO DO
ANYTHING.
THAT WILL COMPROMISE.
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THE
INTERESTS.
UP FOR CALIFORNIANS.
SO I WILL NEVER TAKE A MEASURE
OF WHICH A MEASURE OF FORWARD.
THAT WILL COMPROMISE
CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST OR
CALIFORNIANS INTEREST.
HAVING SAID THAT.
THIS IS A EXTREMELY WELL
PROTECTED.
EVERY AT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
OVER THE FIVE YEARS I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL.
EVERY COMMITTEE IT'S GONE
THROUGH I'VE TAKEN MORE
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE.
THAT IT WILL NEVER CAUSE DAMAGE.
TO THE BOTTOM LINE INTEREST
WHICH IS STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
OUR RESIDENTS.
IN ORDER FOR THIS BILL.
IF IT'S PASSED AND SIGNED INTO
LAW. TO ACTUALLY TAKE A FACT.
A FEDERAL ACTION WILL HAVE TO BE
TAKEN.
AGAINST THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY.
WHICH IN ITSELF [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
A LOT.
PRETTY LARGE TASK.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEN AS AN ALLY.
IN THE REGION.
SO FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S A BIT OF A STRETCH
ALREADY.
EVEN SHOULD THAT HAPPEN.
THE LANGUAGE IS VERY SPECIFIC AS
TO WHAT KIND OF ACTION.
AND THE ACTION IS GOING TO BE
ALONG THE LINES OF IF.
HE DOES NOT.
RECOGNIZE THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
SAID IT'S NOT JUST ANY FEDERAL
ACTION.
PRESCRIPTIVE TO SPECIFIC ISSUE.
IF IF THOSE TWO ITEMS.
ARE OVERCOME AT THAT POINT.
CALPERS AND CAL STAR STILL HAVE
THE AUTHORITY. TO SAY THAT THEY
WILL NOT GO AHEAD AND IMPLEMENT.
BECAUSE OF FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY.
SO I KNOW THEY WOULDN'T WANT TO
BREAK GO AGAINST THE GOVERNOR
NOR.
NOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR AN ACT
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN. TO RESERVE
THAT RIGHT.
SO GIVEN ALL THE DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
GUARD RAILS.
SECURING THE INTEREST OF
CALIFORNIANS -- THIS IS MORE OF
A MESSAGE A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE.
THAT A HUNDRED AND FIVE YEARS
LATER HUNDRED AND FOUR YEARS
LATER PLUS.
CALIFORNIAHAS NOT FORGOTTEN.
ASIDE FROM PASSING THE ANNUAL
RESOLUTION THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE PAST. TWENTY FIVE YEARS
PLUS.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
NEXT STEP.
IN ENSURING WHAT IN HUMAN HOW WE
ADDRESS AS A SOCIETY AS A
CIVILIZATION AS A STATE.
MAN'S INHUMANITY TO MAN.
NOW IF THE WORLD HAD COME TO A
CONCLUSION IF THE WORLD
COMMUNITY I'VE TAKEN STEPS TO
HOLD TURKEY ACCOUNTABLE.
WE MAY HAVE NOT SEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN TURKEY TODAY.
BECAUSE THE WEST DID INVEST IN
TURKEY AFTER WORLD WAR.
ONE THE POINT WHERE IT HAS
BECOME A TOP TWENTY FIVE GDP
WORLD CONTENDER.
AND IS SPIRALING DOWN NOW.
BECAUSE THE CURRENT REGIME IS
TRYING TO GO BACK RATHER THAN
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE REFORMS.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS OF GOOD.
COMPETITION IS A GOOD THING WE
ALL ESPOUSE THESE IDEAS.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN DOING
EXACTLY THAT AT A MORE LEVEL.
THIS WILL THIS BILL WILL NOT BE
IMPLEMENTED.
I REALLY DON'T THINK IT'LL EVER
BE IMPLEMENTED BUT IT WILL.
ALWAYS BE IN THE BOOKS IF IT
PASSES AND IT'S SIGN.
AS A SIGN THAT WE ARE WATCHING
OVER.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE VOTING
FOR SO I DO HOPE BY ON YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT WAS A VERY NICE CLOTHES I
APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THIS IS.
BECAUSE AS AMENDED. TO JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
HILL AYE HILL AYE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
HOLD WILL OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ALL [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO
[inaudible]
YOUR WELCOME [inaudible]
YOU HAVE. THREE BILLS.
ON OUR AGENDA.
AND IF IT WORKS WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B.
SIX SEVENTY THREE IS THAT --
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THIS THING ON IT IS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL.
SIX SEVENTY THREE MORE EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES.
WHO ARE NOT PAY THEIR WAGES ON
TIME?
I TOOK THE AMENDMENTS TO RESTORE
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S ABILITY
TO PURSUE A BIRD OF BUREAU OF
LABOR ENFORCEMENT OR BOTH THE
INVESTIGATION ON A AND A THIRTY
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
HAS IN CURRENT LAW.
RECEIVING YOUR PAYCHECK ON TIME
IS A BASIC GUARANTEE OF
EMPLOYMENT AND AS A MATTER OF
DIGNITY AND WORKER RIGHT.
HOWEVER WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN
LOWWAGE INDUSTRIES WAIT DAYS
WEEKS EVEN MONTHS SOMETIMES TO
RECEIVE THEIR PAYCHECKS.
THIS YEAR THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
ISSUE THE LARGEST CITATION IN
THE STATE.
FINDING A CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
NEARLY TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR REPEATED WAGE THAT
VIOLATIONS WHICH LEFT OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS WAITING WEEKS.
AND EVEN MONTHS FOR THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW EMPLOYEES HAVE
NO DIRECT RECOURSE WHEN THEY ARE
NOT PAID ON TIME.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S ABLE TO
RECOVER A PENALTY WHEN WAGES ARE
NOT PAID ON TIME BUT ACCORDING
TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER THIS
PENALTY HAS NOT BEEN COLLECTED.
EVEN IF THE PENALTIES WERE TO BE
COLLECTED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
THE PENALTIES GO TO THE STATE
NOT THE WORKER.
UNDER AB SIX SEVENTY THREE THE
PENALTY IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING WILL BE PAID TO THE
AFFECTED EMPLOYEE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THIS BILL WILL HELP STRAIN THE
MOST BASIC FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
OF SIMPLY GETTING YOUR PAYCHECK
ON TIME.
WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
HOMELESS.
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY.
HAVE A PAYCHECK TO BE ABLE TO
PAY THE RENT ON THEIR MORTGAGE
ON TIME.
WITH ME HERE TO TEST OF IT --
TESTIFIED TODAY IS THE NOW THAT
WOULD BOND WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR WORK
RIGHTS AND KATIE FEISS TERRACE
STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK.
THANK YOU BILL.%
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
WE WILL ENTERTAIN SHORTLY.
THANK YOU FREE.
FOR SIX MORNING MR I CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DANIELLE URBAN I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR WORKERS RIGHT.
SACRAMENTO BASED LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDER FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS.
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR AB SIX
SEVENTY THREE BECAUSE UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE IS NO
PRACTICAL REMEDY FOR EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE NOT PAID ON TIME. FOR
MANY EMPLOYEES TO LIVE PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK LATE PAYMENT OF
WAGES CAUSES EXTREME FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP.
AND RIFF THEIR ABILITY TO PAY
FOR FOOD RENT AND THESE.
LABOR CODE SECTION TWO TEN
CURRENTLY ONLY ALLOWS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO RECOVER THE LATE
PENALTY IN AN ACTION BROUGHT.
EVEN IF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE WAS EXERCISING ITS
AUTHORITY UNDER SECTION TWO TEN
WHICH IT IS NOT.
THE PENALTIES ARE PAID TO THE
STATE AND NO RECOVERY IS
PROVIDED TO THE WORKER.
I CURRENT RECOVERY UNDER LABOR
CODE SECTION TWO TEN THROUGH
LITIGATION IS NOT REALISTIC FOR
MOST EMPLOYEES WHO SIMPLY WANT
TO BE ISSUED THEIR PAYCHECK AND
SOME COMPENSATION FOR THE LOSSES
CAUSED BY THE LATE PAYMENTS.
AB SIX SEVENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUAL WORKERS TO RECOVER
THE PENALTY ALREADY PROVIDED IN
SECTION TWO LABOR CODE SECTION.
TWO TEN THEIR LABOR COMMISSIONER
WAGE CLAIM PROCESS OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE BERMAN HEARING
PROCESS.
WE AT THIS A HUNDRED THE WORKERS
EACH YEARS WITH THEIR BERMAN
HEARING CLAIMS AN THIS WOULD
ALLOW US TO RECOMMEND THAT THEY
ADD PENALTIES WHEN THEY AREN'T
PAID ON TIME.
CURRENTLY THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ADD ANY PENALTIES
WHEN NOT PAID ON TIME.
THIS BILL ALSO WOULD ALLOW THE
LABOR COMMISSION TO CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE THE PENALTIES THROUGH
ITS EXISTING PROVISIONS
INCLUDING THROUGH THE BOTH THE
MECHANISM.
THE CHANGES TO LABOR CODE TO TEN
ASK PROPOSED IN AB SIX SEVENTY
THREE CREATES A DETERRENT FOR
EMPLOYERS. TO ISSUE PAYCHECKS
LATE IN THE HOPE THAT NO
EMPLOYEE HAS TO SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF LATE PAYMENT.
AND WE URGE TODAY AND I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF CLIPPERS PLEASE PROCEED
GOVERNMENT IN AND A HALF SELECT
A GOOD ACTORS GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KATHERINE VYSTAR I'M AN ATTORNEY
AT LEGALLY THAT WORK.
IN THE WAGE PROTECTION PROGRAM
WE HOLD SEMI MONTHLY LABOR
COMMITTEE -- WAGE CLAIM CLINICS
AT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE WE SEE THIS ISSUE ALL THE
TIME AND TIME IN AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN OR FORCE TO TELL OUR
CLIENTS.
THAT THE RECORDS FOR THEM RIGHT
NOW IS AS BLEAK I WANTED TO
SHARE JUST TWO QUOTES FROM A A
TWO OF OUR CLIENTS.
WHO HAVE -- WHO ARE PAID LATE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN -- BANDS
SIMPLY ASKING TO SEE MY PAYCHECK
IS ENORMOUS AND UNPAID.
IT IS DEMORALIZING TO HAVE TO
ASK FOR MONEY THAT I HAVE WORKED
HARD TO EARN.
IT IS ALSO VERY STRESSFUL AND
ANXIETY FROM NOT KNOWING IF AND
WHEN I'M GOING TO BE PAID JUST
GROWS.
ANOTHER CLIENT I LIVE PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK AND ON MY WAY JUST
TO SUPPORT MY FIVE YEAR OLD SON
AND WIFE.
I RELY ON MY WAY JUST TO PAY OUR
RENT BUY FOOD AND PAY OUR BILLS
IT'S FRUSTRATING NOT KNOWING.
WHEN I'M GOING TO BE PAID I
WORRY ABOUT HOW I WILL PAY FOR
MY FAMILY'S MONTHLY EXPENSES?
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO LEGALLY AT
WORK BECAUSE OUR LOW WAGE WORKER
COMMUNITY AS MOST VULNERABLE TO
LATE PAYMENT OF WAGES.
THE CURRENT LAWS FAILING ARE
HARD WORKING CLIENT COMMUNITY
AND AB SIX SEVENTY THREE AS IF
THERE REMEDY TO THAT.
I URGENTLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TESTIMONY.
COMMITTEE DOES AS WELL OTHERS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND DRY RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAP BROAD FOR THE TEAMSTERS
EIGHTY YOU UNITE HERE ENGINEERS
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
WORKERS AND OTHERS THANK YOU.
RENEE BY OUR OSU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THEIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND MY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSORS
ORDER SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR BETTER BECOME AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THIS BILL WE WERE OPPOSED TO
A PRIOR VERSION OF THE BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY THAT HAD A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF AND THESPONSORS
GRACIOUSLY WORKED WITH US. TO
REMOVE THAT PROVISION IN SO WE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
PUBLICLY THANK THE ALTAR FOR
DOING THAT SO.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF DOES MONEY
TODAY THANK YOU.
JOHN.
MISTER CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF A NUMBER OF CLIENTS AND I
WON ACT.
SUCH COMMENTS WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
MAY BE.
NOW ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
RATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DESERVE
TO BE PAID ON TIME AND THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT THERE'S A REMEDY
FOR THAT TO DO THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIGHT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR MITCHELL TO DO
PASSED IN JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
HILL AYE HILL AYE MORRELL.
WELL NO JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE.
US TO VOTE IT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
[inaudible]
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL PROTECT THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIAN FINISHER ELEVATOR.
AND ESCALATORS ARE CONSTRUCTED
UP TO THE CAL OSHA STANDARDS.
STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT NO
ELEVATOR OR ESCALATOR BE
OPERATED WITHOUT A VALID AND
CURRENT PERMIT ISSUED BY THE
ELEVATOR UNIT WITHIN CAL OSHA.
HOWEVER CERTAIN ELEVATOR
COMPANIES HAVE BEGUN
INCORPORATED INCORPORATING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES AND
CONVEYANCES AND HAVE KNOWINGLY
INSTALLED ELEVATORS THAT FAIL TO
COMPLY WITH CAL OSHA BUILDING
STANDARDS.
AFTER THE COMPLETION OF THESE
PROJECTS THE COMPANY THEN SEEK
TO REMEDY THROUGH A VARIANCE
APPLICATION THROUGH FROM CAL
OSHA.
AS A RESULT THERE ARE GREAT
PRESSURES.
ON PUBLIC AGENCIES SUCH AS
SCHOOLS OR UNIVERSITIES WHICH
ARE THEN FACED WITH REMOVING AN
ELEVATOR COSTING SEVERAL
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ARE FILING FOR AN EXEMPTION AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT PROVIDES THAT
A PERMIT TO BUILD OR WORK ON A
CONVEYANCE MUST BE TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDED IF THE WORK
PERFORMANCE THE TERM AND TO
VIOLATE.
BUILDING CODE OR OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY STANDARDS THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES THE PERMIT HOLDER WITH
A NOTICE OF PERMITS SUSPENSION
AND GIVES THE HOLDER AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO CONTEST THE
SUSPENSION.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IS MISTER MIKE MONICA NUMBER
HAVE THE INTERNATIONAL UNION.
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCT A
CONSTRUCTORS LOCAL EIGHT AND
EIGHTEEN WELCOME TO CHAIR
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
I'M SORRY SENATE MITCHELL --
MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE HALF THE
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS UNION AND
SPROUT SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. TO
VERY NARROW BILL AS THE NOW
ASSIST POINTS OUT THE CALIFORNIA.
HAS THE ABILITY NOW TO SUSPEND A
PERMIT TO CONSTRUCT A CONVEYANCE.
THE BILLS THE DISTINCTION IS
THAT UNDER OUR BILL.
THEY WILL SUSPEND.
THE PERMIT TO CONSTRUCT UNTIL
THE ISSUES SURROUNDING THE
SAFETY OF THE INSTALLATION ARE
DEALT WITH.
YES REMOTE THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANYONE HERE.
THEIR SUPPORT THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA'S ON SUPPORTER YOU
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEE
KNOWN -- IS OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
AND I DO THE FLOODS.
MENTION IT TO THERE IS SOME
CONCERN THAT THIS BILL MAY GROW
INTO SOMETHING OR CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE AND AND OTHERS.
REALIZATION THAT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE BUT IF IT DOES WE'LL.
BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT TIME HE
WILL BE THE FIRST TO KNOW THANKS
VERY MUCH MONEY.
IT'S GOING TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
WHICH IS THE APPROPRIATIONS.
IS IT IS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MIX.
OF THE SECOND THE MOTION BY A
SENATOR MITCHELL. TO LOOK
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU THERE ARE UP.
JUST A FEW FLOORS IN OUR
BUILDING AND SOMETIMES WE GET
STUCK IN OUR OWN ELEVATORS I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE AND
SOME OF THIS ACTUALLY COMES TO
LIFE AND OTHER PLACES AROUND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS A COMMON SENSE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR GOOD
THANK YOU AND I THINK THE
PROBLEM THAT I I HERE IN OUR
DISTRICT IS THAT THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH ELEVATOR INSPECTORS.
TO DO AN ADEQUATE JOB OF KEEPING
THE INDUSTRY GOING. FOR SURE
THAT'S CORRECT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
COULD BE A BUDGET.
CHALLENGE AND GET MORE FUNDING
FOR CAL OSHA.
WE HAVE THE BUDGET CHAIR HEREBY
WHO WORK ON THE YOU HAVE A
SOLUTION DEVELOPER PROCREATION
I'M SENATOR MITCHELL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CENTER HILL AYE.
AYE MORRELL [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL. TO VIRTUAL THE ROLL
OVER ON THAT FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AS WELL NOW MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I AM ON A
ROLL TODAY.
YOUR THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND A MEMBER.
AB PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE THE METHOD
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS HAVE HAVE THE
DESERVE OPTION OF A STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND EXPEDITIOUSLY A
PATHWAY TO JUSTICE IN THE CASE
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS WRONGDOING.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS
NEEDED BECAUSE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS TO SERVE A CLEAR AND
DIRECT LEGAL AVENUE TO BE
DRESSERS COMBINATION AND
RETALIATION.
BY THEIR EMPLOYER BASED ON THEIR
STATUS AS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND STALKING MUST%
PROVIDE JOB PROTECTION TIME OFF
TO SEEK MEDICAL LEGAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE WORKPLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN THESE RIGHTS
ARE VIOLATED SURVIVORS ARE OFTEN
LEFT WITHOUT LITTLE OR TWO NO
RECOURSE.
TODAY SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHO EXPERIENCE
MISCONDUCT AT THE HANDS OF THEIR
EMPLOYER ARE ABLE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
HER PURSUE THE CLAIM UNDER THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PAGA.
THESE EXISTING OPTIONS ARE OFTEN
INEFFECTIVE REMEDIES THAT CAN
TAKE MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS. TO
PROCESS AS A RESULT IN THE
SURVIVOR RECEIVING A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF SINGLE CIVIL
PENALTIES RECOVERED. FOR LABOR
CODE VIOLATIONS A RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT 30% OF SURVIVORS
REPORT REPORT EITHER HAVING BEEN
FIRED.
I OR FEARING TERMINATION BECAUSE
OF THEIR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATIONS AND 34% REPORT HAVING
TO QUIT A JOB.
BECAUSE OF THEIR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION.
THIS BILL WILL PROMOTE ECONOMIC
STABILITY FOR SURVIVORS BY
EMPOWERING THEM TO OBTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION THINK JUSTICE
THROUGH.
ASSISTANCE IN NEGOTIATING THE
RETURN TO WORK OR THE RECOVERY
OF THEIR LOST WAGES.
YOUR TO ATTEST TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL IS LARRY DOYLE WITH
THE CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND JULIA PERISH
WITH THE LEGAL AID AT WORK.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE MORNING [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
ON BEHALF OF THE THE CALIFORNIA
BAR ASSOCIATIONS -- THIS IS A
WE'VE ALWAYS HEARD THAT --
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED IN THIS CASE.
YOU HAVE AS CLEAR SITUATION OF
THAT BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH VICTIMS
IN THESE -- CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES -- DO HAVE.
POSSIBLE REMEDIES REMEDIES ARE
EITHER INEFFECTIVE OR INTO MANY
CASES ARE -- IS A NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF SUBSTANTIAL
BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS UNDER THE
RELEVANT SECTIONS.
YET TO BE DECIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT.
YEAH AN DIDN'T.
WE NEED TO HAVE -- QUICKER MORE
EFFICIENT WAY OF VACANCY OKAY
GETTING THEIR REMEDIES SO WHILE
WE'VE AS FOR THIS AND WE HOPE
YOU WILL SUPPORTER QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MORNING -- MY NAME IS
JULIE A PARISH AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK.
OUR SURVIVE PROGRAM EXISTS
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP ENHANCE THE
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE OF
SURVIVORS AND OF VIOLENCE.
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE IS.
CRITICAL TO MAINTAINING SAFETY
AND FOR SURVIVORS AND WE HEAR
FROM HUNDREDS OF SURVIVORS A
YEAR WHO FACED THE EXACT
PROBLEMS THAT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO SPOKE TO THEY GET FIRED
THEY LOSE THEIR JOBS AND WHEN
THEY CALL UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF GREAT OPTIONS THAT
I HAVE TO OFFER THEM.
AND WHEN WE ALLOW CERTAIN GROUPS
OF PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN OR DISABILITY.
THE ABILITY TO FILE A LAWSUIT
BUT WE DENY SURVIVORS THAT
ABILITY WERE REALLY REINFORCING
THE MESSAGE THAT THEY ARE
SOMEHOW LESS WORTHY AND THAT
THEIR RIGHTS.
ARE NOT WORTH THE SAME
PROTECTION THAT OTHER PEOPLE'S
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS ARE.
AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
AT GIVE SURVIVORS WHO ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE AND TO
THESE SORTS OF EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION BECAUSE THEY THEY
NEED THAT FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE
SO MUCH.
EVERY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN IN
ORDER TO EFFECTUATE THERE RIGHT.
AND THEN AS AND MY FELLOW AND
SUPPORTERS POINTED OUT
SPECIFICALLY THAT LABOR CODE
SECTIONS TWO THIRTY INTO THIRTY
POINT.
ONE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE
ARE ONLY THIRTY NINE CLAIMS
FILED AT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FOR VIOLATIONS F THOSE LAWS.
AND AT THIS POINT ONLY THREE OF
THOSE ISSUES NOT EVEN THREE OF
THE ENTIRE CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
SETTLED THE REST OF THEM ARE.
STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION AND
THAT IS SIMPLY TOO SLOW.
SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS.
ARCHER SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OTHERS HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MORNING.
CHRISTINE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND MYSTIC VIOLENCE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORNING CAN L<c.cyan>G ON BEHALF OF</c>
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN BEG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
RENEE BAYARDO ESSAY YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THERE'S IN SUPPORT.
MORNING IN THE MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS THAT HAVE
BECOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T CONDONE
DISCRIMINATION OR RETALIATION
AGAINST -- SURVIVORS OR VICTIMS
WE HAVE PARTICULARCONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL IN THE CREATION OF A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
ENFORCE THESE CLAIMS.
WANTED TO POINT OUT THE BILL
THAT CREATED THE LEAVE
PROTECTIONS FOR THESE CATEGORIES
OF EMPLOYEES SENATOR JACKSON'S
BILL SB.
FOUR HUNDRED FROM TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ORIGINALLY CONTAINED A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION BUT
BEFORE THE BILL SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR THAT PRIVATE READ
RUSSIAN WAS DELETED FROM THE
BILL.
SO WE THEREFORE DON'T SEE NEW A
NEED TO CREATE A NEW PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION HERE.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERN WITH THE
PARTICULAR LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
THE BILL SAYS AN EMPLOYEE MAY
ALSO FILED A CIVIL ACTION IN
ADDITION TO AND LABOR
COMMISSIONER CLAIM IN A POCKET
CLAIM.
AND WE'RE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
THAT MEANS BUT WE HAVE CONCERNS
OF THAT COULD RESULT IN THREE
SIMULTANEOUS -- PROCEEDINGS FOR
THE SAME VIOLATION.
JUST A QUICK NOTE ON THE LABOR
COMMISSION -- RETALIATION
PROCESS -- THERE'S THERE'S SOME
STATISTICS IN THE ANALYSIS WE'VE
TAKEN A LOOK AT THE REPORT I
THINK WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON THE
PICTURE THAT THOSE -- SISTER.
SIX PAINT.
FIRST OF ALL TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX CASES WERE
FILED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOR
RETALIATION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE CASES
INVOLVE CLAIMS UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTION NINETY EIGHT POINT SIX
OR ELEVEN A TWO POINT.
FIVE ONLY FIFTY SEVEN OF THE
ALLEGATIONS OUT OF FOUR THOUSAND
ALLEGATIONS OR POINT 001% FELL
UNDER LABOR CODE SECTION TWO
THIRTY INTO -- THIRTY ONE SECOND
WHILE TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX RETALIATION CASES
WERE OPEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DEAL SEE CLOSE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN CASES.
AND FINALLY DEAL SEES REPORT
CONCLUDES THAT THERE ARE ONLY
FOUR CASES REMAINING UNASSIGNED
AT THE END OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO CASES.
THAT NOT YET BEEN ASSIGNED AT
THE END OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
THERE'S ALSO BEEN FURTHER
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE RETALIATION
PROCESS CENTER HERTZBERG HAD
LEGISLATION SB THREE OF SIX FROM.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO IMPROVE THE
THERE'S A CLEAN UP LEGISLATION
OF THAT THERE'S BEEN BUG ME.
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS. TO THE
RETALIATION UNIT SO.
IT'S NOT A PERFECT PROCESS BUT
WE THINK THERE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN RECENT YEARS AND
THAT IT IS AN EFFECTIVE PROCESS.
WHEN FINALLY WEEK WE JUST DON'T
THINK A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
IS NECESSARILY A PANACEA IN ALL
CASES -- AND THIS IS A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL -- FROM LAST
MONTH THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION'S
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY SUBMITTED TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SENATOR MITCHELL MAY
BE FAMILIAR WITH THIS ASKING FOR
MORE RESOURCES FOR THE PARKING
UNIT WHICH NOT REVIEWS BARGAIN
NOTICES AND REVIEWS SETTLEMENT
CLAIMS AND AND THEY SAID IN THAT.
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL QUOTE.
75% OF THE ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS REVIEWED BY THE PAGI
PAGI UNIT AND FISCAL YEARS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
RECEIVED A GRADE OF FAIL OR
MARGINAL PASS REFLECTING THE
FAILURE OF MANY PRIVATE
PLAINTIFF ATTORNEYS TO FULLY
PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF THE
AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE.
THE THOSE ARE MY WORDS ARE THE
WORDS OF THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THOSE WORDS OF THE NEW SAID
ADMINISTRATION'S LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE DON'T
THINK A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
IS NECESSARILY THE BEST SOLUTION
IN ALL CASES THAT WERE POST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS HERE IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO ALLOW MY COMING OUT OF
CHAMBERS.
SEAN WAS THE NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS CONCERN LITIGATION ISSUES
AS DESCRIBED ALSO OPPOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
QUESTIONS.
NONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I'LL ASK THE QUESTION WHY IS
THIS BILL NECESSARY AND I'LL
RESPOND BY SAYING -- CURRENTLY A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR CAN
FILE RETALIATION OR
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
OR PURSUE A PRIVATE RIGHT.
A PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT
PAGA THAT ALLOWS AN INDIVIDUAL
TO PURSUE OTHER REPRESENTATION
REPRESENTATIVE ACTION ON BEHALF
OF THEMSELVES OF TIMER LEMME.
AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEES AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER IN ORDER TO GET A PAGA
CLAIM STARTED THE WORKER MUST
FILE A CLAIM WITH THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
WHICH IS A SEPARATE
ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY.
AND THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND SORRY IN THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND IS GIVEN
SIXTY DAYS TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
PURSUE AN ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION.
THE THING TO KEEP IN MIND WITH
PAGA IS THAT THIS IS A WAY TO
RECOVER PENALTIES ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE.
SO IT DOES NOT REALLY WORK FOR
CLAIMS UNDER TWO THIRTY OR TWO
THIRTY POINT.
ONE PAGA IS USED FOR CLAIMS LIKE
UNPAID WAGES OR MISSED MEALS OR
REST BREAKS WHERE THERE ARE
DISTINCT VIOLATIONS OVER VARIOUS
PAY PERIOD AND PENALTIES.
I CAN ATTACH FOR EACH VIOLATION.
A RIGHT A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION PROVIDES THE EMPLOYEES
WITH CONTROL OVER THEIR OWN CASE
AND ALLOWS FOR THEM TO FALL
DIRECTLY WITH THE CIVIL COURT
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS OR BE
LIMITED TO PART OF PENALTIES.
THIS IS AT THE END OF THE DAY OF
BILL THAT PROTECTS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS THIS IS THE
VALUES OF OF OUR STATE.
AND IT ALLOWS THE SURVIVOR TO
CHOOSE WHEN AND HOW THEIR
COMPLAINT.
IS HEARD AND HOW THEY CHOOSE TO
PROCEED.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE PUTTING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL WE
HAVE A MOTION TO TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL HI HILL AYE MORRELL.
WELL NO JACKSON.
I I CAN.
THE BILL HAS TO GO TO HOLD THE
ROLE OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD BILLS TODAY.
I SAW ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
WE WERE MOVING NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B. TWELVE
TWELVE GOOD MORNING THANK MEMBER
VERY MUCH CENTERS A. B. TWELVE
TWELVE WOULD REQUIRE CALTRANS.
D. W. R. OTHER AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE A PRIORITY INVESTMENT
LIST TWO PENSION BOARDS ACROSS
THE STATE CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS THAT NEED
TO BE MADE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THIS OF COURSE DOES NOT REQUIRE
ANY INVESTMENT IT JUST MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING THOSE
INVESTMENTS HAVE INFORMATION
THAT HELPS THEM IDENTIFY
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS WITH ME.
TODAY IS.
GIVEN THE ONE FROM A SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
REGULAR HERE THIS.
STILL GIVES THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT'S IT'S NEED TO HAVE THIS BILL
HERE THE AS IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THE
DIVESTMENT BILLS THAT YOU SEE.
THIS IS ONE THAT ENCOURAGES
INVESTMENT RATHER THAN
ENCOURAGING DIVESTMENT.
AGAIN IS THE THE AUTHOR SAID
THIS ISN'T.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE CALPERS
RECOUNTS STIRS -- MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS -- BUT JUST AT THE
STATE PROVIDES THIS.
PROVIDES THEM WITH THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO INVEST
IN CALIFORNIA INVESTING
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS BEST IN
CALIFORNIA JOBS -- AND USE THAT
MONEY TO TO BENEFIT THE
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
AT A. B. TWELVE TWELVE I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WELL.
A GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
THERE'S OF GALEN DOBBINS WHO
WORKS HERE AS WELL [inaudible]
THIS.
SOUP AND NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I I JUST HAVE A QUESTION YOU
KNOW THE AGENCIES CAN DO THIS
TODAY.
CORRECT I MEAN THEY'RE JUST NOT
DOING IT IN THIS JUST KIND OF
PRICE THEM TO THAT'S RIGHT IT'S
ALL SOMETHING THAT COULD BE DONE
IT'S NOT OCCURRING ARE PENSION
BOARDS STURGEON PERSON
PARTICULAR THEY MAKE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA
AND IN FACT.
OUTSIDE THE UNITED STATES.
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THEY'VE
GOT THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED AND YOU KNOW WE FEEL THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THAT IN.
FOR HI AND THIS WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DO AND THEY CAN MAKE
SOME WISE INVESTMENTS HOPEFULLY
AND AREN'T IN OUR STATE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN THAT WILL BE A CLOSE ASIAN
LAWS THAT WORKS THANK YOU.
WE WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK I'M WELL I COULD DO THAT
THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THIS
IS A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
I CAN THE BILL HAS TO GO TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CENTERS I THINK WE
SHOULD.
I SAW A ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
WELCOME.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B..
TWELVE NINETY ONE GOOD MORNING
RIGHT.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU TODAY.
LEAVE US TO CONFIRM GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWELVE
NINETY ONE CLARIFIES THE TIME
FRAME WOULD CANNABIS BUSINESSES
NEED TO COMPLY WOULD LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT REQUIREMENTS.
A LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT IS AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE BUSINESS
AND THE LABOR ORGANIZATION THAT
PRESCRIBED APPLICATION A BEACH
PARTY.
THESE AGREEMENTS TEND TO INCLUDE
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL PROVISIONS
THAT PROTECT BUSINESSES.
AND AND EMPLOYEES AS PARTY
APPLICATION PROCESS TO OBTAIN A
CANNABIS LICENSE THIS IS THIS
WITH AT LEAST TWENTY EMPLOYEES
ARE REQUIRED TO STATE THAT THEY
WILL ENTER A LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT IF THE BUSINESS THAT.
HAS NOT ALREADY INJURED ONE
HOWEVER CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
SILENT ON WHEN BUSINESSES WITH
LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES NEED
TO ENTER THE LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT IF THEY BECOME
EMPLOYERS OFTWENTY OR MORE.
REGULATIONS ONLY SAY THAT THIS
REQUIREMENT NEEDS TO BE MET AS
SOON AS REASONABLY UP PRACTICE.
BUT WHAT.
ARE WHICH IS VAGUE AND OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION AB TWELVE NINETY
ONE WILL REQUIRE CANNABIS
BUSINESS LICENSE APPLICANTS
EMPLOYEE LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES TO SUBMIT A STATEMENT
THAT THEY WILL ENTER LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
EMPLOYING.
THEIR TWENTIETH EMPLOYED THIS
MEASURE WILL PREVENT ARBITRARY
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AND WILL PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES WITH CLARITY -- WHEN
AN EMPLOYER IS FAILING TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW WITH ME TODAY? TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURES JAZZY GRAY WALL FROM
UFC W. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK ME EITHER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING.
THE MORNING AT CHERRY MEMBERS
SAID JACKIE GROWTH UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL I HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE ON THE BILL.
THE OTHER IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT.
MISTER SURE MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND SO IT.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS AND THEN IS THERE A
MOTION TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
I'LL MOVE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHNSON OKAY.
BACK TO ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL TO
DO PSSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE. TWO VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
I SAW ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
ARAMBULA THERE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THIS IS WEIRD NOW IT ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE I'M HERE
TODAY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE REGARDING
SKILLS CERTIFICATIONS IN THE
GROCERY INDUSTRY.
GROCERY STORES LONG TERM
CONSUMER TRENDS SHOW THAT THERE
IS AN INCREASED INTEREST IN THE
PERIMETER OF THE GROCERY STORE.
WHICH INCLUDES THE BAKERY DELI
DAIRY PRODUCE NEED ANOTHER
SPECIALTIES.
CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING MORE
FRESH PREPARED MEALS.
AND THAT THE BE LOCAL.
FRUIT AND PRODUCE.
AND ARE CUTTING PROCESSED FOODS
FROM THEIR DIETS SOMETHING I
THINK WE ALL SHOULD TRY TO DO.
AND THE GROCERY INDUSTRY IS
RESPONDING TO THESE CONSUMER
DEMANDS BY INCREASING IN STORE
FOOD PRODUCTION.
ADDING MORE LOCAL PRODUCE AN
ADDING DINE IN OPTIONS AND
SWAPPING THE CENTER AISLE WITH
FRESH AIR GOODS.
WITH WHILE THESE CHANGES HAVE
BEEN BENEFICIAL FOR CONSUMERS
AND GROCERY STORES IT IS
NECESSARY.
FIRST IN THE PERIMETER OF THE
STORE TO RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING TO KEEP UP WITH THESE
CHANGES.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE ENSURES
THAT WORKERS RECEIVE THE
NECESSARY TRAINING. TO ADAPT TO
THE CHANGING NATURE OF THE
GROCERY INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL IS THE ESTABLISHES
THREE CERTIFICATIONS.
FIRST THE PRODUCE CLERK
CERTIFICATION WILL REQUIRE
TRAINING AND HEALTH CODE
VIOLATIONS.
LOCALLY SOURCED PRODUCE PRODUCE.
NUTRITIONAL FACTS CULINARY USE
OF PRODUCE AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
SECOND THE SERVICE DELI
CERTIFICATION WILL REQUIRE
TRAINING IN FOOD SAFETY HEALTH
CODE VIOLATIONS FRESH FOOD
PREPARATION AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AND THIRD THE NUTRITION CLERK
CERTIFICATION WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING.
ABOUT FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
SPECIAL DIET PLANS BUDGET
RESTRICTIONS NUTRITION EDUCATION
AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT EMPLOYEES
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING
TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH
CORRECT INFORMATION. TO MAKE
HEALTHCARE DECISIONS.
I HAVE SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS TO
THIS COMMITTEE THAT ADDRESSED
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OR JAZZY GRAY WALL ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I APPRECIATE THAT.
I'LL KEEP IT SHUT AGAIN HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS AS
YOU GROW WITH UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THATTHOSE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SIR FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION THE BILL.
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN.
DRAFTING IS AMENDMENTS I THINK
THAT REALLY WORK MY SOLUTION
THANK YOU.
INTO THE COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY
CONCERNS QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ABOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU.
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATOR HILL I KNOW I'M RURAL.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE. THREE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THE FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MOVING NOW AND I APOLOGIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
WILL BE LAST ON THE LIST TO THE
HE BUT NOT LEAST OF COURSE NEVER.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
PROBLEM SURE YOU ALL ARE A GLAD
THIS IS THE LAST -- GOOD MORNING
I THINK IT IS YEAH IT IS -- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA -- THE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA CALLED A CENTERS JOB
ACT.
OF CALL CENTERS ARE MAJOR
ECONOMIC FORCE IN THE UNITED
STATES REPRESENTING ABOUT 3% OF
ALL OF OUR WORK FORCE.
YET THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE CONTACT CENTER JOBS HAVE
DECLINED IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND A
LARGELY DUE TO OUTSOURCING AND
LAYOFFS.
IT HAS BECOME ALL TOO COMMON FOR
CORPORATIONS TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF STATE FUNDING AND
SUBSIDIES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
EXPORTING JOBS OVERSEAS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
CORPORATIONS HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STATE SUBSIDIES WERE FUNNELING
CALL CENTER JOBS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE SHUTDOWN OF JUST FIVE OF
JUST FIVE CALL CENTERS FROM ONE
COMPANY RESULTED IN NEARLY.
A THOUSAND MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
LOST.
CORPORATION SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
OUTSOURCING AND TO CONTINUE
SUBSIDIZING CORPORATIONS THAT
EXPORT CALL CENTER JOBS ONLY
SERVES TO INCENTIVIZE THIS
BEHAVIOR.
CASA JOB SHOULD BE BASED IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS SEEKING
TO RELOCATE CALL CENTERS JOBS
FROM CALIFORNIA TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY GIVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS NOTICE.
IN ADDITION EMPLOYERS WHO EXPORT
CALL CENTER JOBS OVERSEAS WOULD
BE PROHIBITED.
FROM RECEIVING ANY STATE GRANTS
GUARANTEED LOANS OR TAX CREDITS
FOR FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
COULD CURRENT COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA AND SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION CAN I SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL IS LIST SORENSON THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR CW A
DISTRICT [inaudible]
NINE WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND ALSO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN MY NAME IS LIZ
SORENSON I'M THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT.
NINE AND OF COURSE I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVEN
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BECAUSE WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
SO CALL CENTERS ARE IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC LIFELINE FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WITH TWO HUNDRED IN
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND WORKERS WITH THE
JOB TITLE CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE.
BUT THOUSANDS OF CALL CENTER
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
IN RECENT YEARS AS MAJOR
CORPORATIONS HAVE OFF SHORED
SERVICE OPERATIONS OVERSEAS.
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN FOR EXAMPLE
A. T. AND T. HAS CLOSE CALL
CENTERS IN ANAHEIM BAKERSFIELD
ATWATER SACRAMENTO OAKLAND.
AND ATG IS ALSO SEVERELY REDUCED
ITS WORK FORCE IN SAN RAMON
FRESNO SAN DIEGO COMMERCE
PASADENA ESCONDIDO AND TORRANCE
IN MAY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SPECTRUM FORMALLY KNOWN AS TIME
WARNER CABLE CLOSE ITS CALL
CENTERS.
IN PALM DESERT WITHOUT WARNING
LAYING OFF TWO HUNDRED WORKERS.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY FOURTEEN
RISE IN WIRELESS CLOSED IT'S
CALL CENTERS IN OUR IRVINE AND
EMPLOYED OVER ONE THOUSAND
WORKERS.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
COMPANY CLOSED ITS CALL CENTER
IN RANCHO CORDOVA ALSO LAYING
OFF OVER THOUSAND WORKERS THIS
TREND HAS HARMED WORKING
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS AMERICA.
WHILE ENDANGERING CONSUMER
SECURITY BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE
CALL CENTERS IN COSTA RICA OR
HOME TO A MASSIVE TELEMARKETING
SCAMS THAT DEFRAUDED THOUSANDS
US CITIZENS MOST OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE OF UPWARDS OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
WITH NEW TAX PROVISION IN THE
TRUMP TAX BILL COMPANIES ARE
EVEN MORE LIKELY TO MOVE THEIR
CUSTOMER SERVICE WORK OVERSEAS
ACCORDING TO THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON TAXATION THE NEW TERRITORIAL
TAX SYSTEM EXAMS.
OFFSHORE INCOME FROM US TAXATION
COSTING TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
BILLION OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
FOR CORPORATIONS TO MOVE JOBS
OFFSHORE TO COUNTRIES WITH LOWER
TAX RATE COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
PROVISION AFTER THE FEDERAL TAX
BILL PASSED. EIGHTEEN TEASE
COMPANY THAT NETTED TWENTY
BILLION FROM THE TAX SAVINGS HAS
ELIMINATED OVER TEN THOUSAND
CALL CENTERS IN THE U. S..
WITH THE LEGISLATORS IN NEW YORK
IN ALABAMA RECENTLY PASSING
SIMILAR LEGISLATION. TO PROTECT
CALL CENTER WORKERS IT IS TIME
THAT WE ALSO PUT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS FIRST.
THAT WE HAD NEW LEVELS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE OFF
SHORING PROCESS AND ENSURE THAT
WE ARE NOT REWARDING COMPANIES
WHO ARE ACTIVELY ELIMINATING
GOOD JOBS IN OUR STATE.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE JOB STATE
IN CALIFORNIA IN THAT IT
PROTECTS CONSUMERS.
ALL IT DOES IS PROVIDE NOTICE IF
A COMPANY OFFSHORE 30% OF ITS
CALL CENTER.
WORK AND LIMITS ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE GRANTS GUARANTEED LOANS
AND INCENTIVES FOR FIVE YEARS IF
A COMPANY OFF SHORES 30% OR MORE
OF ITS CALL CENTER.
AND AT THE END WHY SHOULD
CALIFORNIA TAX CREDITS GO TO
COMPANIES THAT OFFSHORE THEIR
JOBS.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY WEBER. FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AS IMPORTANTLY IN OF
COURSE FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FOR
COMMUNICATION WORKERS AMERICAN
OF COURSE I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT A. B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN GOOD MORNING
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS TO ME THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM ARE HAVING
TO SUBSIDIZE THEIR COMPANY
MOVING JOBS OVERSEAS.
CW WAY HAS HELPED TO CREATE THE
MIDDLE CLASS IN THE STATE AND IN
THIS COUNTRY THROUGH GOOD UNION
JOBS AT EIGHTEEN T. AND AT THIS.
WE ARE SUBSIDIZING THE CUT THE
COMPANY AS THEY ELIMINATE THESE
JOBS.
THE STABILITY AND THAT THESE
FAMILIES THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES FOR THEIR CHILDREN FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND FOR THE
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE.
AND SO WE STAND HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT BUT THE MEMBERS OF CW A
TO SAY THERE MUST BE
ACCOUNTABILITY YOU CANNOT USE
OUR MEMBERS MONEY TO OUTSOURCE
THEIR JOBS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
ARE JENSEN FEET OF YEAH NINETY
FOUR FIFTY NOT OAKLAND WORK ALL
WOULD LIKE TO THE YOU CAN LINE
UP BEHIND THERE IF YOU'D LIKE
ERIC FINNEY CW A NINETY FOUR
FIFTEEN I'M IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CW A
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GEORGE WINSTON CW A NINETY FOUR
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
MARSHALL IRVING CW A NINETY FOUR
FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WANT TO BRITAIN'S NINETY FOUR
FIFTEEN AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING THIS
MORNING GOOD MORNING ROBCOTE CW
A NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WRITING IS ALSO
UNDER TWENTY THREE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING JOHN JAMES NINETY FOUR
FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ALLOW THE SALDIVAR
CITYREALLY NINETY FOUR TWENTY
ONE SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING RANDY DOWN WITH CW
A NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE A
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DAVID JACKSON
NINETY FOUR FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING JAMES WALKER NINETY
FOUR FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING.
FLOOR SANDERSON NINETY FOUR
TWENTY ONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SCOTT TURNER CW
NINETY FOUR FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GRACIE CUT NINETY
FOUR TWENTY ONE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING AND CHAVEZ CW A
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE IN
SUPPORT MY JOB CURRENTLY IS
GOING TO FLORIDA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE HI MY
NAME IS PAM COIN MC TO BE A
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE I AM IN
SUPPORT.
AND I HANDLE THE BILLING FOR A
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COUNT THAT
CUSTOMERS I HANDLE THE BILLING
FOR EDT DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES.
OF EDUCATION AND MY JOB WILL BE
VACATING THE STATE [inaudible]
YOU.
VIRGINIA WHETHER BE.
THE W. H..
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE AND MY
JOB IS GOING TO THIS.
OUT OF STATE.
AND I HANDLES THEY'VE NEVADA AND
LOVE STATED CON.
A CALIFORNIA CONTRACT AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THOSE ARE CW A NINETY FOUR
TWENTY ONE AND ARE MY OFFICE IS.
WITH THEM BUT IT'S ALSO GOING TO
SAY.
THANK YOU.
YOUR SUPPORT.
THAT WAS MY SENSE.
I DON'T KNOW JUST CAME TO ME
THAT WAY.
DARCY SHE AND CW A NINETY FOUR
TWENTY ONE IT'S THANK YOU.
ADD TO WISH A FOR CW A NINETY
FOUR TWENTY ONE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT VERY GOOD WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MERRY RACE CW A
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HAVING COME OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL I THINK WE HAVE
SOME FUNDAMENTAL PHILOSOPHICAL
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT WHETHER THIS
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH WE WANT.
TO CONVINCE BUSINESSES THE SAME
CALIFORNIA WE THINK WOULD BE
MORE PRODUCTIVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY REDUCING SOME OF THE
REGULATORY BURDEN ON A
BUSINESSES.
WE WANT TO KEEP THEM HERE RATHER
THAN A PUNITIVE APPROACH.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL'S IMPACT ON ATTRACTING
FUTURE CALL CENTER JOBS THE
CALIFORNIA AND THESE CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR A COMPANY TO
CONSIDER.
CREATING A NEW CALL CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA IF THEY THIS BILL
GOES INTO EFFECT WHEN THEY SEE
THE POTENTIAL RAMIFICATIONS IF
IN THE FUTURE THEY MAKE A
DECISION TO LEAVE SO WE THINK
IT'S GONNA IMPACT JOBS IN THAT
[inaudible]
LEVEL.
SO DESPITE OUR FUNDAMENTAL
OPPOSITION WE TRY TO ENGAGE
OFFERS ALL AUTHORS OFFICE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE ABOUT
AMENDMENTS AND DOCTORS OFFICES
BEEN.
VERY GRACIOUS IN A MEETING WITH
US AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THE
AUTHOR HAS.
TAKEN US FAR WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS.
WE THINK THE NOTICE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
SIXTY DAYS TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE WARN ACT WHICH IS A SIXTY
DAY NOTICE REQUIREMENT.
THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS OF THE TAX
CREDIT PROVISION.
DOES NOT HAVE A NEXUS TO TAX
CREDITS CENTER FOR JOB CREATION
OR OPERATIONS OF THE CALL CENTER
AND SO YOU COULD HAVE A LARGE
COMPANY THAT HAS -- ONE CALL
CENTER FOR ONE DIVISION -- AND
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
WOULD POTENTIALLY IMPACT TAX
CREDITS AT A COMPLETELY SEPARATE
PART OF THE COMPANY RECEIVES.
TAX CREDITS THAT MAY BE USED TO
CREATE OTHER JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A TIGHTENING UP OF
THAT PERHAPS THE NEXUS -- FOR
THE TAX CREDIT PROVISION.
THE REMAINDER OF THE BILL DEALS
WITH THE CONTRACT AND WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THOSE
PROVISIONS AS WELL. FOR US IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW THIS BILL RELATES TO
A EXISTING PORTION OF THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTS CODE THAT WAS ENACTED
BY A WE NEED A BILL BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE PUBLIC
CONTRACT COULD SECTION.
TWELVE ONE FORTY THE BILL DEALT
WITH CERTAIN STATE PROGRAMS CALL
CENTERS THAT SERVER CERTAIN
STATE PROGRAMS LIKE HOW WORKS
AND CAL FRESH.
THAT SECTION OF THE LAW EXCLUDES
CERTAIN PROGRAMS FROM THAT FROM
THAT A PROVISION OF THE LAW.
IT ALSO SAYS THAT THOSE
LIMITATIONS DON'T APPLY IF THEY
WOULD VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW ARE
VIOLATE SOME TYPE OF FEDERAL
TRADE AGREEMENT.
IT'S UNCLEAR FROM US WHETHER
THIS BILL SUPERSEDES THOSE
PROVISIONS OF THE LAW.
SO WE HAVE SOME CONCERN ABOUT
HOW THE TWO PROVISIONS.
RELATE.
FINALLY.
SEVERAL EXISTING STATE CONTRACTS
ALREADY DEAL WITH OVERFLOW
SITUATIONS CALL VOLUME -- BUT
YOU PROBABLY ALL REMEMBER THE
SITUATION WE HAD IN THERE
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY WHERE
EMPLOYEES WERE CALLING EDT ABOUT
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND
COULD NOT GET ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE.
WAS A LARGE PROBLEM SO SOME OF
THE CONTRACTS WITH CERTAIN STATE.
AGENCY SPECIFICALLY DEAL WITH
CALL VOLUME.
AFTER A CERTAIN NUMBER OF RINGS
IF THE CALL IS NOT ANSWERED IN
CALIFORNIA HAS.
KICKED OVER TO ANOTHER STATE SO
AT LEAST A CONSTITUENT GETS.
PERSON ON THE PHONE.
AND SO THE REASON AMENDMENTS --
DEALING WITH OVERFLOW ATTEMPT TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT IT
MATCHES UP WITH THE CONTRACT
PROVISIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN NEGOTIATED THAT DEAL WITH
OVERFLOW MY UNDERSTANDING.
IS THAT AGAIN SOME OF THESE
CONTRACTS HAVE SPECIFIC LIMITS
OF THE PHONE RINGS A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF TIMES.
AND ISN'T ABLE TO BE ANSWERED IN
CALIFORNIA KICKS TO ANOTHER
STATE THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
DEALING WITH OVERFLOW.
IT HAS TO BE A 30% INCREASE IN
CALL VOLUME -- AND THEN THEY CAN
GO TO OVERFLOW BUT ONLY FOR
FORTY EIGHT HOURS AND WE THINK
THE EXISTING.
CONTRACT PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED DEAL
WITH.
CALL VOLUME AND AND WHEN CALLS
ARE TRANSFERRED TO OTHER STATE
SHOULD CONTROL.
THEY WERE CONCERNED THAT THE
OVER FLOW AMENDMENTS DO NOT LINE
UP WITH THOSE EXISTING CONTRACT
REMEDIES SO. FOR THESE REASONS
AGAIN WE HAVE FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS --
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
COMMERCE AND WILL CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT -- CONSTRUCTIVE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD REDUCE THE
CONCERNED.
WE ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
I CHRISTINA'S BAGNOLI CAL
BANKERS OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA MAY
PRISON TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
TOO ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO WEEK --
WANTED TO ADD TO WHAT THE
CHAMBER WAS SAYING REGARDING
CONCERNS WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT IN MANY CASES WE HAVE
MANUFACTURERS WHO LIEU PROJECTS --
THROUGHOUT THE THE WORLD AND
WHILE THEY MIGHT BE MOVING A
CALL CENTER THAT'S ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT PROJECT MIGHT NESS IS
NOT NECESSARILY BE A PERMANENT.
RELOCATION WHICH IS A TEMPORARY
LOCATION RELATED TO THAT PROJECT
AND WE NEED THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
DO THAT AND WE'RE NOT CONVINCED
THAT THE BILL COVERS THAT AND
NOW THAT SITUATION ALLOWS FOR
THAT.
KIND OF ACTIVITY AS IT RELATES
TO A PROJECT THAT MIGHT ALSO
HAVE A FEDERAL -- YOU KNOW
CONNECTION SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE LIKE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORS
OFTEN TRY TO WORK THAT OUT BUT
AND FORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL
POSTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CONVERSATIONS.
WOULD YOU LIKE T RESPOND TO THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW YOU.
HAD SOME YEAH SURE THE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE.
YOU'RE HAVING THOSE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
TRYING.
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED IN
AND I KNOW IS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO JUDICIARY WILL HAVE
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH
THEM AND SEE IF THERE'S AGAIN
LIST SORENSON WITH CW A DISTRICT.
NINE I'M I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
TO THE SIXTY DAYS THAT THEY
BROUGHT UP -- I I WILL TELL YOU
THAT AGAIN THIS BILL IS ABOUT
JOBS IT'S ABOUT WORKERS AND WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SIXTY DAYS.
YOU KNOW RECENTLY I'LL GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE WE JUST HAD HERE IN
THIS STATE ONE OF THE EMPLOYERS
THAT WE REPRESENT WHICH IS
EIGHTEEN T. THERE WAS.
THREE HUNDRED AND I BELIEVE
SIXTY EIGHT EMPLOYEES THAT WERE
LAID OFF ESSENTIALLY SOMEWHERE
PLACE SO WE ENDED UP WITH LIKE
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY THIS WAS
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
THE WARN ACT DID NOT APPLY IN
THE REASON THAT IT DID NOT APPLY
BECAUSE HE'S OUR TECHNICIANS
THAT ARE SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
STATE IN GARAGES.
SO IT DIDN'T MEET A QUOTA THAT
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
IT RIGHT IN ONE LOCATION THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT BUT I WILL TELL
YOU.
WHEN YOU ARE THE PERSON AND WE
ARE BECAUSE WE REPRESENT THESE
WORKERS AND WE HAVE TO TELL THEM
THAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS?
AND THEY HAD LITERALLY THE
EMPLOYER I THINK GIVEN LIKE
SEVEN WEEKS I DON'T EVEN THINK
IT WAS THAT LONG.
WHEN YOU HAVE TO TELL SOMEBODY
YOU ARE NOW TO FIND A NEW JOB IT
WAS DEVASTATING SOME OF THE
STORIES OUT THERE?
CHAU.
PERSONALLY I DON'T KNOW WHY
ANYBODY WOULD QUESTION A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS WE ARE GOING TO
TRY TO GIVE THESE EMPLOYEES AS
MUCH TIME AS POSSIBLE. TO GO ON
SOME OF THESE FOLKS HAD JUST YOU
KNOW ONE FAMILY MEMBER WORKING
THAT MEN NO INCOME COMING IN SO
AS MUCH TIME AS POSSIBLE THAT WE
CAN GIVE THESE EMPLOYEES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IS NOTIFIED
SOMETHING AS DEVASTATING.
AS LOSING THEIR JOBS ARE GOING
TO DO THAT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
SIXTY DAYS IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE FOR THOSE REASONS
WE REALLY SUPPORT THE HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS I HOPE YOU ALL DO TO
THANK YOU.
YEAH AND I AND I WILL SAY THAT
IN ALABAMA AND IN NEW YORK THE
BILL THAT PASSED THE DID PASSED
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS.
THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE ACOSTA
HERNANDEZ ALSO BEHALF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE I'M ON THE ISSUE
OF THE THE CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE AS FAR AS CALL CENTERS --
THAT PARTICULAR A PROVISION OF
THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAS BEEN
MEETING WITH A NUMBER.
DO THE WORK NOW -- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA M. AND WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF OVERFLOW AND AND
OTHER AND TRANSFERS ANOTHER
SHE'S LIKE THAT.
SO THE LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE NOW
IS REALLY A BY PRODUCT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS.
AND SO A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
WERE MENTIONED TODAY'S THE FIRST
THAT WE'VE HEARD THIS FOR SOME
CONCERNS AS FAR AS BEING IN
PARTICULAR CODE SECTION --
THAT'S FOR THAT WE'VE HEARD
EVIDENCE THAT I'M AWARE OF IT
HAPPY LOOK AT THAT BUT AS FAR AS
WORK ABILITY IS.
IT'S BEEN RAISED TO US WHAT IF I
A CALL CENTERS TO TEMPORARILY
CLOSE -- WHAT IF THERE'S
NEGOTIATED OVERFLOW SITUATION SO
ALL OF THE MEMBERS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN TODAY ARE BASED OUT OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS OR HAPPY TO WE
THOUGHT WE ADDRESS THOSE THAT
THERE ARE NO?
OTHER ENTITIES ARE NOT HERE
TODAY THAT WE THINK THAT WE
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND
THEY'RE DOING THE WORK RIGHT NOW
THE CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THEY SEEM TO BE -- IT'S
NOT A 100% PRETTY CLOSE TO BEING
OKAY WITH THAT MA'AM SO PUT
FORTH TO ALWAYS HAPPY LOOK AT IT.
EVEN FURTHER BUT WE THINK THAT
WE'VE ALREADY GONE PRETTY FAR.
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT APPRECIATE THIS
TERMINATION WANNA MAKE ONE MORE
COMMENT TO ON THE STATE CONTRACT
STUFF YOU JUST HEARD MANY OF OUR
FOLKS AT ACTUALLY HAVE LIKE THE
COUNT YET.
THAT THEY WORK WITH AND THAT
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC ON CALL CENTER.
AND A LOT OF A MENTION THAT
THEIR JOBS ARE GOING TO BE
LEAVING THE STATE.
I I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FRUSTRATION ABOUT THAT HERE
WE HAVE AN ENTITY THAT HAS A
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT YET THE VERY
WORKERS THAT THEY HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THEY'RE GOING TO
BE DOING IT SOMEWHERE ELSE
THAT'S JUST NOT RIGHT THERE
SOMETHING.
WRONG WITH THAT PICTURE RIGHT
AGAINST WE'RE LOOKING AT
TAXPAYERS MONEY IN CONTRACTS
THAT WORK IF THEY'RE CONTRACTING
THESE CALL CENTERS THOSE JOB
SHOULD STAY RIGHT HERE IN THE
STATE AND I THINK THAT SHOULD BE
IMPORTANT EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WELL CALIFORNIA'S.
WHAT ARE ALSO IN OUR WORK?
WHEN WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT BOTH THE TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
CALL CENTERS REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA?
AND THAT THE JOBS REMAIN HERE SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A FACTOR
THE COMMITTEE IS.
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
THIS IS DUE PASSED THE TRADITION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE.
HILL AYE MORRELL.
MORRELL NOW JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE PAN.
IT HAS TO VOTE TO HOLD THE ROLL
OVER FOR THE AFTER MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES THE
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT WE HAVE.
YEAH. TWO WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN NOW AND WE'RE CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO ADD ON TO THE I THINK YOU'RE
WILL YOUR BY.
YOUR WORK IS DONE.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO BRING IT TO YOU
TOMORROW
.
WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR A
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MORALE
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH
PROCREATION SENATOR MORALE.
MORRELL NOW JACKSON.
IT WILL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN ON
TWELVE NINETY ONE MOVIE NOT A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN PLEASE CALL THE AFTER
MEMBERS.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MORALE
[inaudible]
WELL NO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RIGHT.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW OF RUN
THROUGH THE ROLE AND THE COLD
THE ABSENT MEMBERS -- ON THE
BILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB.
THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR PAN.
AND I FOUR VOTES THAT BILL IS
OUT WILL MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IF WE COULD.
AND FALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR PAN HI CAN I THE CONENT
CALENDAR IS OUT WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE AB.
AB FIVE TWENTY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
PAM. FOR VOTE IT IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE AFTER MEMBER.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR.
CAN I THE BILL IS OUT I REMEMBER
SEVEN A. B. SIX TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR PAM.
HI FOUR VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBERS EIGHT AB SIX FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE AFTER
MEMBER.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR PAT. FIVE
VOTES IT IS OUT.
NOW MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER TEN A.
B. SIX SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTION IF TO PASS TO DO DISH
HEARING COMMITTEE SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
JACKSON I FOUND.
HI THIS FOR VOTE IT IS HOPED
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT AND THE MOTION IS THE
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
JACKSON.
JACKSON I AM.
YES WE DID.
THE BILL IS FOR VOTE IT IS OUT.
MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
A. B.TWELVE TWELVE PLEASE BY
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION HAS TO
PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON I AM [inaudible]
I FOUR VOTES SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
I REMEMBER FOURTEEN A. B. TWELVE
NINETY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
AFTERMATH.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON I SENATOR PAM.
I FOR VOTE SO THAT IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN TWENTY
PLEASE CALL THE AFTER MEMBER.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SENATOR
JACKSON.
SENATOR DR I AM.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS
OUT.
I REMEMBER SEVENTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER PAN.
HI THIS FOR VOTE IT IS OUT I
REMEMBER NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL WE HAVE TO MEMBER MOTION IS
THE PAST TWO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
ACCESS I AM.
CAN I THE BILL IS OUT OF THE
FINAL BILL ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE OPTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SENATE
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE YEAH RIGHT.
IT HAS FOUR VOTES IT IS OUT TECH
INCLUDES THE BUSINESS.
THAT CONCLUDES THE LABOR AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR TODAY